Good googly move.
Me Ladies and gentlemen
actually lie. That's it.
Actually live. It's that easy.
We don't fuck around anymore, man.
That's pretty cool. It's beyond cool.
Um, this video that you gave
me, let's get right to it. Yo.
First of all, I love the characters and
I see a reality show in your future.
I see a parody of, of, of, uh,
like a duck dynasty type moonshiners type
of situations are real far better with
music. Okay. Fuck it.
Just genius guys who live out in the
desert who just happened to make amazing
music and be completely retarded
and think they're,
I think they're a punk rock band.
No, that's fucking great. It's,
it's really interesting what you're
doing. I love how you're, you know,
you don't have any roles.
We just do whatever the fuck
you think is interesting,
creative and mix the two of them
together. I mean credit, you know,
credit where credit is due when it,
when it comes to working
with Lauren Milligan and Mike
King, uh, her husband, uh,
large, just like, she'll just go
off on a tangent and I'll just,
just film it. And you know,
and we just kind of go with it.
So if you pick the right wig for the
bright tangent, then you just go,
I like what you did to, or you're
mixing different styles of music,
you're mixing like legit country music
and then some of the songs sound almost
like tool.
You know,
some of the sounds have like your
same type of vocals that you would,
one of your tool songs,
but it's just got this
completely different extra
vibe to it. Yeah. I think, uh,
I think there's a,
there's a lot of flexibility just
because we are kind of a moving target.
So why don't we start to kind of
get inspired in some direction.
We're not where they can find
to, you know, I love slayer,
but slayer. Slayer, right?
Yeah. They're not gonna all of a sudden
put out a country record. Yeah, no,
that's kind of one of
the cool things about,
I really enjoy what you're doing that
you just do whatever the fuck you want to
do. You don't, you don't have
a box that you have to fit in.
You're just doing what
you feel like doing. Like,
I know what it never expect you wearing
a wig and playing this character. I mean,
he calls he fucking,
you ride it too man.
It's not like you just like
play it at the beginning. No,
I fucking keeps coming back and it's
really funny. Shit man. It's really funny.
Shit. Thank you. What does,
what inspired you to make like a
half country, half comedy half?
You know what I mean? It's like, it's just
this, I think just watching, you know,
I think we talked about this last time
like a Monty python movies, right?
They're just,
there is no,
you can't really pin him down and like
the meaning of life just, you know, it's,
that's Kinda how we did this
new DVD is there's a whole,
the whole documentary is at the
beginning, you know, when you go, what,
I'll watch the DVD again. You can actually
skip the documentary if you want to,
but it was important to see the
documentary and see, you know,
Billy Dee and Hildy Burger,
uh,
so that you understood when they came
back up later in the actual show.
Who the hell? Who the fuck is that? If he
didn't, if he didn't see the documentary,
you don't understand where those
people are when you do the live shows.
Do you play the documentary first?
That's our opening band.
It's a great idea, man.
And the live DVD that you found, was that
in Phoenix? Did you film it in Phoenix?
Phoenix? Still repping Arizona
baby. That's where we are.
If you've seen the,
uh,
there's been a lot of camera trap photos
of Jaguars are starting to cross the
same paths from Mexico into the
United States. That the, uh,
the drug guys do jaguars
the cars. No, no, no.
Jaguar is in the native
North American giant cat.
Yeah. Yeah. There's, uh,
there's, well we have like,
I guess are they called Pomona's or,
yeah,
the mountain is up around us,
but we haven't actually,
I haven't actually seen
the jaguars coming out.
Yeah,
there's not that many of them and they're
starting to take photos of them on
camera traps.
Apparently a long time ago they were
native species in North America.
Now they're starting to make its way
through your, your town. Excellent. Mm
indeed. So a is winemaking
season over for you now?
Yeah, I just wrapped up, uh,
had a good year. A lot of,
a lot of interesting challenges,
a lot of stuff that came up that um,
I wanted to try,
um,
stuff that was going to give me a
hard time kind of giving me trouble.
Well that's another perfect example
of you just not fitting in a box. Oh,
he makes wine. Like you just,
you don't just dabble in it.
You have a fucking vineyard, like a
full time set of employees, a vineyard.
You produce an excellent wines, a bunch
of different ones. It's really good stuff.
You know what you're doing. It's, I mean,
you just threw yourself into wine maker.
Okay. Yeah. I mean that's
one of those, you know,
you could pretty much read the back of
east packet to figure out like what to do
to inoculate fruit. But you know, to
really actually learn how to make wine,
you just got to dive in. You know, you can
go to explode, you can go to college to,
to get all the nuances and be taught
how to make wine with fear in mind,
but just dive in and make it.
It's really,
it's not that difficult to get over the
first basic comp of like the one oh ones
of it. It's not that hard. Then you know,
after that then it's like the nuances,
the,
you know,
the upper percent of just
intuition and instincts, you know.
Do you mingle it all with the people
in the wine world? Like do you,
do you communicate with other people in
the wine industry and gas guys at speed
dial that I know that are world class
wine makers from around the world and if I
have a, I have a question
that I think that they can,
that they've seen the answer to or seen
that challenge, we're seeing that hurdle.
I will not even hesitate to text or
call or write or email or you know,
something just to go, okay, so here's
the, here's the challenge. I'm your,
or here's the thing, I'm going
to try and based on, you know,
the kind of fruit that we get because
the fruit we get is not like it would get
in Napa or get in a necessarily get in,
uh,
New Zealand.
It might be more specific to like Adelaide
hills but not necessarily the Barossa,
you know, so there's, there's, you
know, different stuff, parts of Spain,
maybe parts of Italy maybe.
Do you do anything to your soil or
do you just let it be what it is?
For the most part, you let, you
know, you have to kind of give a,
I'll give it some, some food now and
then some kind of nutrients that are,
that are not going to come. They're
not going to like cripple, you know,
you don't want to give it steroids
or anything like that. I get it.
But you want to, you want to
give it something that it needs.
If it needs a little extra doses.
So what do you do? Do you add
like minerals or, yeah, yeah.
I guess if there's something that it's
kind of short on and how would you know
petioles you take the, you
know, samples from the plant,
you take samples from the
soil. Uh, we have, uh,
for moisture we'd take it
to have a pressure bomb,
the pressurizes the leaf to see if it,
how much women wash straight
actually needs today.
Wow. You give it like, if it
wants 10, you give it nine. Yeah.
That's a thing about the grapes for wine.
They're supposed to suffer a little bit.
Right. Why is that? Uh, it just, it just,
it just gets some stronger. I mean, you
know, you train Jujitsu that's there,
you know, there's
suffering involved. Yeah.
I couldn't get anywhere unless you are
pushed a little bit. Even as a grape,
even as a grape. How many,
even as a salary, Joe,
even as a salary. I see, I
see. Now it all becomes clear.
How many years you've been doing this
now? Uh, I broke ground and around 2001,
2002, um, made my first wine in 2004.
I find that absolutely fascinating.
I've never once heard of a,
a Rockstar who decided to not
just make wine. Like, I mean,
I suppose Sammy Hagar has it Tequila,
right?
How much is he really involved in it?
Is Sammy out there harvesting at Nga Bay?
You know, is he a, is he pressing it
and I'm saying, yeah, I don't know.
Think so. Okay. I don't think so. He's
definitely not doing what you're doing,
man. You're, you're, I mean, cause you
know, for me, I have, I have, uh, my staff
sitting room. So basically come
to Jerome. There's like, you know,
there's a staff of people that, you
know, of course rotate. But, uh,
we have Chris Turner's like my
right hand man and the vineyard.
I'm not a vineyard guy.
I'm, I'm in the cellar.
So Chris has his team of people in the
actual vineyard making sure that they all
have their finger on the pulse of what
I'm looking for in the grapes to make the
wine. We have, of course our
shipping staff and you know,
the business affairs managers and
stuff. But in this, in the cellar,
it's just my wife and I, it's
just us making the wine, uh,
pressing the grapes and acculate ing.
So there's not actually a staff
of people in the actual seller.
Cause that's my house. Wow.
So it's just us doing it.
So I don't think people quite understand
like, uh, he can't make it. It's harvest.
So wanted his employees handle that.
There's,
I don't quite think he'd
been listening to me.
There's nobody in the cellar but
me. I mean, we have a couple guys.
I have a friend down the street that
comes up and cleans up after me. Um,
have a guy that comes out at
the beginning of the season,
I'll buy some new equipment
that I don't know how to use.
I Bill Greg makes that work. He'll
go, okay, I'll read the directions.
We hate reading directions. So I'll just
have Greg figure out how to make that,
make that go.
How do you piece together a team?
Like when you decide that you're going
to start making your own wine, you,
you get a piece of land, you decide
where you're going to grow grapes.
You decide here, how did the fucking
piece together a team to create wine.
Anything else? It's hit and miss. You
got to just figure out who has natural,
you know,
natural talent toward it or is it ready
or willing to do all the work if you
have any, if they're not even
naturally. I mean my wife doesn't,
she's not a chemist, but
she works the lab. She went,
I went and guess what you're
doing. So she's like, I am.
So you're nine years into
production essentially,
but the 10 1112 years into this project,
is this still challenging for you?
Do you still enjoy,
you know, every, every year that I'm
making wine on my, on my own, you know,
previous years,
like from Oh four up to about
a 2009 I had other people,
I was kind of like looking over their
shoulder and trying to be involved in
doing it, but until 2010,
you know, like part the,
but the part of 10 until I was
actually in, you know, doing it myself.
Uh, you're only going to learn
that way. And so, you know, that's,
it's just,
you just dive in basically.
Wow.
And now how many months out of the year
does it take to do that and then the
rest you devote to whatever else? Like
postal for anything else if you like doing
and anything else? Yeah. Um, yeah. Uh,
don't even look for me on August
1st August 1st and November 1st.
Don't even look, I'm
not around. I'm dug in.
So for four months you're gone.
Yeah. Yeah. Do you enjoy that,
that you're committed to this
like four month project, that,
that list for four months you're accounted
for. That's it. This is your life.
Yeah. I mean it's, it's
nice to know that, you know,
I'm going to be sleeping in my own bed,
right. And it's, you know, it's hard work.
You're up,
you know,
I'm up at six 30 doing punch downs and
just checking things out and make sure
everything's, you know, not, you know,
something didn't blow up or
I forgot to seal something.
So it's leaking or you know,
there's just those,
those tragic things that
kind of happened in the end.
The seller that you look over and like
the spouse wasn't shut and there's like
peanut grief pouring onto the
ground and like foc, bonehead,
move Brent over and shut it.
This, that, that it's, it's
such an interesting idea,
but I love the fact that you figured out
a way as a musician to guarantee that
your home for four months, you know,
like people don't know the musicians are,
comics aren't,
that fucking road gets sad man.
It gets so boring and it gets so,
it gets,
it gets grueling body,
you know, as you go forward in time, uh,
there's no going back in time. What
was your back doesn't get it. You know,
it doesn't get stronger from the journey.
It gets weaker.
Yeah.
Especially the travel.
We were talking about a guy that you know
that had a blood clot from an airplane
ride and was feeling shit.
And I was telling
you how I flew back from England
and got sick. The flights,
every flight is like going on a bender.
It's like getting hammered.
Every one of them is just like,
just wrecking your body like Ah,
and skidding into home plate and it was
fun. I'm laying in the bed, not, yeah,
it's very, very weary. Okay.
It really beats you down.
So then when that's over,
November's done.
Dee Dee had just chillax for a little
bit or uh, last couple of years.
Now I would jump right into,
you know,
doing some stuff with perfect circle or
puts a for if the guys were writing with
the tool,
work with them or maybe we go out and
do some quick tour or something, but,
and that's all it,
just to kind of keep it alive and because
you've done some work that you need to
kind of tidy up and do something with.
Like we came up with conditions of my
parole and I had to, like, I had to,
I had to promote that records. I had to
get on the road right away in November.
Uh, that was a couple of years ago. So,
and then between you add some Jujitsu?
Yeah, that was the fun part this year.
It's like, watch it, like
poor Matt Mitchell from poster for you.
Came out to like record some
tracks with me and uh, you know,
I'm up at six, seven out there doing my
thing. And that would come in and like,
we tried to like work on a song or work
on some tracks and he was helping record
some stuff. And, uh, and then I
go, I gotta go, I gotta do the,
I gotta quickly destemmed these,
this fruit.
And then at 1145 I got to drive down the
hill cause I gotta go do Jujitsu from
noon to one and then I'll be
pack up here at one. Okay.
I'll be here at one 15. We can do a vocal,
but then I got to press the Chardonnay.
He's like,
who the fuck are,
are you,
and he's known you from long before this?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I toured with him.
First Time I met him was
on a perfect circle tour.
So what do these people think that I've
seen you prewired and post one or they
like, did they think of originally
like, God, this is just his new thing.
He'll do it for a little bit and
then it's probably, you know,
it'll last a year or so, 12
years later, 12 years later.
How many bottles do you make
a year now? Uh, I did about,
I'm horrible mass.
Um,
this year I did about six and a half,
7,000 cases in my cellar.
Holy Shit.
That's incredible.
How many acres are you growing on?
Uh, in northern Arizona, I,
right now I have planted, uh,
40, just under 40 planted. Uh,
and only about 10 of those are
actually producing at the moment.
I'm southern Arizona. Uh, my sister
company, Arizona's stronghold.
I have access to fruit from our
vineyards down there. So, uh,
there's a lot and there's a lot
of growers all over the state. Um,
and there's growers just over the
border into New Mexico as well,
just to it just over from those counties.
So there's also like
kind of a mirror image,
a terrain over in New Mexico with
even more established vendors.
And we have an Arizona,
so 40 acres you're, you're
planting, but only 10
of them are,
you're actually harvesting fruit from
and probably by next year I'll see a
little bit more from the other 30.
And then by, you know, by 2015,
I'll see full production from everything.
How does that work?
Do you have to do something to soil?
Do you have to just get you
to the grapes used to it?
That and the ticks takes you three and
three to four years to see fruit off the
vine. Once you plant that, it's real.
It's a commitment in time for sure. So you
planted and it,
is it just a matter of it growing or is it
and establishing you want to make sure
an adult depends on what you're kind of
going for. You know, if you want,
if you want to plant like tighter spacing
and set free a little earlier on the
plant when it's younger so it doesn't
quite get big and it kind of like almost
stunt its growth in a way. He gets some
really concentrated fruit on, on a,
on a smaller,
on a smaller vine.
But you've seen some that are like
these huge old school of vines.
There's different schools
of thought on that.
You got guys that pull out everything and,
and uh,
20 to 30 years I'll just pull everything
out and start over cause the vine might
produce, you know, an eighth of what
it was producing when it was younger.
And if it's not great,
I mean if it's like prove to these
producing an eighth of fruit and it's
fantastic, just undeniable fruit, well
yeah, hang onto it. But if it's not,
most guys are pulling it out.
Oh let's start over.
Do you find that this whole potatoes,
you know,
the process of creating
this new thing and then,
and then getting involved in
this completely new endeavor,
does that do anything to
the rest of your creativity?
Do you find that it opens up new
possibilities for other things that you,
I get a, I mean it opened yet it opens up
other stuff. Cause you know, when you're,
it's a whole different kind of
creativity and a year when you're,
when you're in the seller and you were
just hovering over some of these wines,
you, you're having to
be kind of, you know,
you have to have the tech,
you know, the technique down.
You have to understand the
process that you're going through,
but you're also have these
opportunities to go, okay,
I have to make a creative decision
right here. There's like a,
there's a challenge that's come in.
Something comes in extremely ripe
that you didn't expect that coming in
extremely ripe because they just were,
the numbers were just all over the map.
The sugars are extremely high and
it's just probably an IB not finished
fermenting. It's so ripe and
then you have something come in,
it's a completely under ripe and you
go, hmm, if I put these together,
they're right there,
right at the right number that I want
rather than trying to finish something
that's not high enough sugar and something
that's way too high sugar. You know,
there's little moments like that that
happen that you just didn't expect and you
can't plan. It's just chaos and you just
have to just navigate the chaos. Yeah.
Would you like a big fan of
wine before you did this?
Or is this just something that you,
you just decided to slowly
but surely step into?
Um, I guess I had a great grandfather
who made wine in northern Italy,
but I didn't know that until I
was actually planting grapes. Wow.
So he just dove in, dove in? Yeah, I
know, but I was into wine a little bit,
you know, back in, I lived in
Boston for Awhile, so I, you know,
I enjoyed wine with my friend Kurt.
He worked at a nice Italian wine shop,
so he'd always bring stuff home on
the weekends and we'd, you know,
he would grill and I would
drink this wine and you know,
let you years later and go,
oh wow. That was pretty,
I think we were drinking some
pretty awesome wine. Yeah.
I don't know shit about one.
I have a really good friend who's a,
he's a real connoisseur.
He has this gigantic room in his house
that he constructed that it's digitally
set to a certain temperature.
And I mean,
he has this ridiculous
clash in the La area. Yeah.
He lives in the Palisades and he's got,
I mean,
he built this room onto his house before
he moved into this house. Mean he's a,
he's a nut and you know,
he can look at blind lists and tell
you what's good this year, what's nine?
He's constantly on top of it. And he took
me to a wine testing for his birthday,
wine tasting.
You know,
they brought up different flights
of wine and it was all good to me.
But hearing describe it,
it's so, it's baffling.
The fruity taste, the
Tannin, the smokey mic,
but like the more people
don't really get does it,
you don't have to know any of that stuff.
If you have it like a good,
if you know somebody you know that's uh,
oh,
it's a cool shop or has a nice
tasting room, like, you know, uh,
Matthew over at Corvelle.
If you just go talk to Matthew about
what they'd have on their list or go to
silver lake wine or talked to Randy or
April of George to go, okay, what's open?
You know,
when you had their tastings and they just
take notes on the of stuff in front of
you. Okay. Write down did I
like it? Did I not like it?
That I like it,
that I not like it.
They just write down what you liked
and we get, didn't like and why?
If there's just a couple words like,
I didn't like that because of this or I
like that because of this, write it down.
And then you just show
them like write down,
have them write down what the wines were
that you had and not so much for you
but for them and come back again and do
it again at for some other flight there
or whatever. And once you have some notes
down, they're going to start to get,
figure out what you might like
and then they're gonna go, okay,
try this or try this and then come back
and tell me if you liked it or not.
I like, I tend to like, like
the fruity or like a Pinot noir.
I like that kind of wine and
just see again does, you know,
don't even gravitate towards the peanut,
just like just taste stuff and then
write down what it was and start kind of
keeping a log or something
of what that was.
Because if you have a
pretty good intuitive person
working at one of those wine
shops, they can kind of go, okay,
having, having poured you have, you know,
a hundred little tastes
over the last couple months,
we've narrowed down what you like.
Do you see yourself going into whiskey
next dude, I love Angel's envy.
Angel's envy. What does that I can't, can
I plug? Sure. Okay, why not? What is it?
It's, it's, it's a, it's a mellow,
a bourbon aged in port barrels.
It's super mellow in port barrel.
So they take the, the older port,
the port it pours out. Yeah, there
is a bigger list. Wow. About that.
By the barrels from somebody.
How does that affect the taste?
Like what is it supposed to do to the
table to tell you? I'm not a guy, but
I like that one. That's it right
there. Angel's envy. There you are.
Hello. Do you see yourself
doing anything else? I mean,
any other crazy ideas you have cooking
in the back burner that you might get
onto? I Cook a little bit, but uh,
I don't think I would actually,
guy wouldn't go be a chef.
I would probably open up like a I.
From that though, I could totally see
you becoming a chef. So were just, well,
it started out I just wanted to open up
a restaurant and one then here I am. Wow.
No wants pizza
and always in Arizona.
Yeah.
I've got a couple,
got a couple of things up my sleeve
and Arizona brick oven, pizza place,
northern Arizona.
It's pretty fucking bad ass.
It's do you live near the mountains
or near Sedona. Oh, okay. Yeah. Yeah.
That's an interesting spot.
Yep. A lot of Weirdos in Sedona.
You think a lot of people,
a lot of people believe in crystal power.
Yeah.
It,
the people you just reach up
and grab their leg and pull
them down to the ground.
It's,
it's to hear what happens to people.
How does that happen where you get a
spot like Sedona for say where it just
people gravitate towards
their healers in quotes?
I don't know. I can't, I
have no answer for that.
I have no answer for it either.
I've always been fascinated though.
It was like how does a spot like that
come to be? And what do you mean you can,
if you've been into, you
know, a decent size city,
there's always going to be a spot.
Like for example in La. Okay.
You got Millie's over on
sunset. What's that? And silver,
like Millie's Millie's cafe.
Millie's the restaurant.
It's a little breakfast
place over on sunset.
That's always going to have a gathering
of people in that spot. Yeah, it's okay.
It's like that moment. I'll never heard
of it. Millie's Millie's on sunset. Yep.
You know where, um, sunset
and one, you know, uh,
just say silver lake just
to, yes, in silver lake,
just a side of a silver Lake Boulevard.
There's a lot of fucking
cool spots down there a lot.
But that's the one that just like no
matter what, no matter who owns that spot,
there's always going to be
people gathering in that
spot for a cup of coffee or
like some kind of opiate know
sunrise kind of event, a Brunch,
you know, even if it's not called
brunch Sunday, just like something,
even if it ends up being a doughnut shop,
there's going to be,
there's always going to be something
there where people gather in that spot and
you kind of have to assign some kind
of value to that energy you're talking
about. It's the Dona until like those
little, we'll call them for Texas.
There's like a, there's some kind of
gathering vortex at that spot. Well,
I think a lot of those places,
especially in La,
they have this deep history of people
returning to these spots and then it's
almost gets like seeped into the wood
places like the comedy store or ever eat
it. Dantanna's no, fantastic place.
It's one of the oldest school old
school restaurants in Hollywood.
It's on Santa Monica,
uh,
right near a boys town and it's this like
super old school bar slash restaurant
that hasn't changed the menu
since 1966 or something like that.
Cooks a fucking tremendous
stake, has amazing pasta.
The waiters all wear Tuxedos.
It was just one of those like super duper
old school spots. That's cool. Yeah.
And when you go in there,
it's like canter's Deli. It
had been a canvas telling.
Yeah. Yeah. That feel like that place
has been used man. It's just uh,
it's in the feel it. Yeah. You know,
you can't get that in a new place.
Cantors in years.
That's a classic as a classic comic
spot because it's open 24 hours a day.
Go there all the time after food
or after, uh, after shows. Yeah.
Cause the Largo is right across the
street. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
La has so many of those really cool old
school spots that I've just been around
for so long.
I think that's, and I think, you
know, back to our SEDONA conversation,
it's probably some version of that
where those spots just kind of have that
energy. And you know, just
in general, uh, I was,
I was driving to a la from kind of the
Sedona Prescott area and I forgot that
the RNL fires,
they were,
they had kind of had the road closed
off so I couldn't go that way,
but I thought it, you know, a month had
passed and I figured everything was fine.
It wasn't fine yet.
So I get to a certain spot and there's
of course a guy standing there,
gone psych,
you can't go this way.
So I had to backtrack and then I kind
of took another route that took me
farther,
kind of back tracked West
Ish and kind of came back in.
And, uh, there's an area out in
that way where it's basically,
it's that kind of Sedona place where
you go there, but there's no people,
there's no cell signal, there's nothing.
It's just these crazy moon rock,
you know, setting with these, uh,
Joshua trees and Cacti just
as far as the eye can see.
And it's like these crazy
rolling hills who this,
it was like the coolest hour and a half,
you know,
added hour and a half to my trip. It was
completely worth. It just goes. He just,
and that, when you see that
kind of place, you can go,
you can see how somebody who,
you know when Sedona isn't there yet,
you can see how somebody would go,
I want to start something here.
There's an energy here that
I want to like, you know,
did you see that video of
those Doby Boyscout guys who
tipped over those hundred
million year old rocks? Did
you see this? You know the,
I think it's called Goblin Canyon.
There's an area of Utah that has these
incredible, did they find the price?
The video,
these dumped fox,
they made a video of pushing over
this hunter. The rocks fall on them.
Unfortunately.
No.
Do is it to pull it up?
Yeah, it's too late.
I don't think you can glue it back,
but what? I mean is it too late to,
to kill them? I didn't say
that all loud. Um, I did.
Um, yeah, they're too stupid to
be held responsible unfortunately.
But they did get fired
from the boy scouts.
Yeah.
Which, yeah, that sucks. But the point is,
it was one of these, a really cool
ancient structures where it's this, this,
this giant like top,
like a mushroom cap almost.
And it's just all this wind and sand
has eroded it to the point where this is
just like this little peak that's
holding this thing in place.
And it was so fucking cool looking
and these tools just decided to,
to tip it over. Did you find it?
What's that adds on all these,
there's ads on them.
Of course there are,
because that's what happens when a
video gets 10 million hits in a week.
Oops. Yeah, no worries.
No worries there. For me,
those structures are so cool though.
It's so,
it's so interesting when you see like
something that's been created by hundreds
of millions of years of
erosion. I was in a, um, uh,
a cave in Colorado. There's
the thing, these, these things.
So that's like,
that's 170 million years old or
something like that. This structure
and these fucking idiots
push this thing along.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's like a Coen brothers movie.
We have now modified
Goblin valley problem.
Valerie exists with the,
this boulder down here,
the bottom hold muscles.
You're hired, you're pushing it off. Yeah.
So sad. But those things, so
the, the, the, the, that area,
Goblin valley is a,
another one of those sort of,
those spots where you drive through it
and it's just has such an inward draw.
Any interesting those fuckheads hopefully,
you know,
people will learn from the reaction
to this and it'll never happen again.
It's still a lot of really cool
shit shit there, but right.
Are you a one time, um, when
I'm one of those, um, uh,
publicity flights for the blue
angels, they took us, uh, uh,
you go down to San Diego and then from
San Diego you cut across like deep into
the desert and it looks like fat.
It has all these incredible rocks and
weird formations and desert and there's
something bad ass about that man. Is
that this is the area. Yeah. Yeah.
There's a lot of spreadable.
Yeah.
And it's all just wind
erosion caused all this stuff.
That's pretty amazing. Yeah.
The, the desert south west of,
of this country has some really fucking
interesting landscape and fascinating
energy to too. I'll try to, I'll try to
text you or email you with the, with the,
uh, the exact area that it was, that I was
driving through. Cool. But you, you know,
you can barely see them.
Make sure you bring water because
for some reason, if you get,
if your car breaks down,
there's no signal. You're not
getting out of there. Yeah.
What do you do? You have to wait for
someone to arrest you. There's, you know,
there's people out there that you can,
you got,
you go by ranches and stuff
throughout in that area. But uh,
yeah, no. Yeah. That's when counting
on humanity gets very sketchy.
You don't realize how vulnerable you are
until your car runs out of gas in the
middle of the desert and
you're like, oh shit. Okay.
This is not just a matter of convenience.
This is a matter of we might
dehydrate to death out here. Yeah.
There was actually a mixed martial
arts fighter, a former UFC champion,
Evan Tanner,
who went on this sort of vision quest
in death valley and disoriented,
lost his water and died side. He was
going to go camping. Don't do that.
Don't get all like into the
wild on people too late.
Yeah, he did it. He died. Yeah,
it was definitely not good.
But he was an interesting cat. He was a
type of guy that, you know, he was uh,
whether or not it was a smart move.
It was a typical Evan Tanner sort
of self discovery type of a journey.
And he did a lot of those and most of
them he came through. But some of them,
you know, this one, obviously
it didn't work out for him.
He was a fascinating guy though.
Really interesting,
very deep thinker, like a deep
original thinker. It's just, you know,
these guys are always
trying to test themselves,
not just inside the cage but in
life period. And for him it was,
I think a bit of a vision quest to go
out there and one of the most extreme
environments known North America.
And test himself or see
find himself. Yeah, I think,
but you know when you're
gonna do a thing like that,
you probably should prepare to be tested.
Exactly.
It's like the end of the wild movie.
The same thing.
I mean the movie's infuriating. The book
is infuriating. The stories infuriating.
There's a seven 11 or right over there.
Yeah, you've done it to do that, man.
I'm only that if you're going to do that,
if you're going to do that into the
wild shit man, you should it take,
if you were really respect nature,
we,
you should fucking prepare
for it for a long time.
You should really know what you're doing.
Like I am in love with
these subsistence shows,
like these shows, like these
Alaska shows where these people,
they live off the land and
trapping and hunting and fishing,
but they fucking know what they're doing
and they've been doing it a long time
and they have like cabins
set up along the way.
Like in case they get trapped outside,
they know that they just have to get a
half a mile down the road and they can
get to this cabin. There's, there's dry
wood inside of it. They can start a fire.
There's matches. Everything's ready to
rock and roll and over prepared. Exactly.
They're ready. I mean they're in Alaska,
it's 50 fucking degrees below zero. If
you're a runner and you're like,
uh,
you know, like send me distance runner,
like a four mile runner or you know,
like a 10 K or whatever.
You do sprints and you do
marathons for training.
You do the extremes and you do it often
and you'd do it well and then you go to
your race.
Well it's also,
if you're going to,
you really do respect that area of you
really do respect the wilderness. I mean,
you've got to prepare for it. You, you,
you really have to prepare to respect it.
It's the only way you can respect it.
Cause by going out there unprepared,
you're disrespecting it and it
doesn't give a fuck about you.
It doesn't give a fuck about your ego.
It doesn't give a fuck how, you know,
a lot of guys might get lost out here,
but I got a natural sense of the woods.
It's not hearing that shit
that's on hearing that shit. No.
It will dry you out and turn
you into coyote food. Yeah.
It's kind of school you for sure.
Do you enjoy the fact that there's
like less humans out where you are?
Do you feel that there's
a benefit in that?
Yeah, there is. Right? Yeah, I absolutely,
I mean, you know, it's, it's um,
it's all a matter of perspective and uh,
I guess it's, it's, it's a microcosm,
macrocosm kind of a situation
where if you're in at the end,
a big city like this,
you're going to see a cross section
of a certain kind of people. Uh,
my friend Todd that I was
just talking about the
talking in reference to,
uh,
just any kind of an
infrastructure or hierarchy.
You got your 10% that are kicking ass.
You got your 80% that are just kind of
coasting. You got your 10% that suck,
so you're going to end up,
if it's La for surfers,
like I was going to a 400 population town,
you're going to have similar percentages.
There's going to be 10% that are that
care and know what they're doing or want
to know what they're doing and then 80%
that are just there and then 10% that
you just want to run over
this.
The one,
the good thing about being in a place
like New York City or la where there's a
large population is there's the 10% is
a larger number and you can cultivate a
good group of them and yeah,
you can see, but you have to,
you have to go out and find them.
Yeah. You've got to find them.
You got keep them close and you got to
feed off of each other and then hopefully
encourage some other people perhaps
that are in the other 80% to break free.
Maybe tip the numbers a bit.
I agree.
When you die 75 cause they're all capable.
We're all capable of learning,
doing.
Do you feel a responsibility for
that or towards that as an artist?
Do you ever feel like because of
what you're doing, because if you're,
you're so motivated,
you get so much done,
you have so many different projects going.
Do you,
do you realize the impact of that?
Because a lot of people
were inspired by though the,
not just the work ethic that you have, but
the, how much quality shit you produce,
whether it's wine or music or,
I appreciate it straight
to compliment. Um, I think, I think
you can't worry about it. You just got
to do what it is you're doing. And for
me, I just have to do what I'm doing.
There's a, there's a, there's a sense of
responsibility for the art or for the,
the process. And just for myself, I
just, I care about what I'm doing. Um,
if I start caring about what
you think about what I'm doing,
whether it's going to be helping you, that
I'm, uh, that I'm, uh, an assisted living,
uh,
employee.
You said something in your video that
was very unpretentious but had the
potential to be massively pretentious.
But it wasn't because
you were being honest.
And what you're saying is that life is
too short to not create with every breath
you take. Right. And but you, you,
when you said it, the audience cheered.
It was a real moment. You know,
they recognize that real moment.
But God damn the wrong person
could say that. And you're like,
well you just shut the fuck up.
Create with every, oh pluse yeah,
you have to get that all the time. But
you really mean it. If you really mean it,
it is inspiring. And that's
where the cheer and the
audience comes from. You know,
the people fucking love that.
They love when someone is
motivated to make shit motivated,
to put out art,
motivated to test themselves creatively.
It's exciting. And, and you know, I'm, I
have a lot of people around me especially,
you know, just within the music,
within the film, within the animation,
like all those things. But especially
in the, in the vineyards and the,
and the restaurant stuff. I see. I
see people that are just every day,
there's like an inspired by their
work ethic. And because, you know,
we were talking about a restaurant,
like that's not, that's not a whim.
That's not something that you can kind
of just start on a whim and not expect to
be responsible for keeping
the boat floating. That's
like, you know, I see. I, uh,
there's a restaurant in,
um,
in Arizona called the F and B [inaudible]
and Charlene and just watching what
they go through and what, but, you
know, not go through it. That's,
that's the wrong way to put it. But like,
just the process, their process and,
and uh, and their motivation and
their, and their fire and they're,
they're derive just,
it's very inspiring. Um,
and then a lot of the winemakers that I
know in the state as well, there's just,
you're watching them go through their
changes and you're watching them go where
they discover a new thing about a new
potential of what they can do and how bad,
how much better they can make
it. And, you know, just see.
You just see that process.
That's really inspiring.
Do you watch any of Anthony Bourdain's
TV shows? You know, he is, yeah.
He's, he had a, the no reservations
and show and now the new show is, uh,
his wife trains with Henzel. Yeah. Yeah.
His wife's good man. That's all I saw.
I saw their kid training there. Was that
last, that hilarious. Yeah. She's bad ass.
She's a at the fights constantly. Um,
I'd never actually met Anthony, but,
and I've seen some of the shows,
but he's a great guy.
He's heard he has a new one that's kind of
fun. Yes. What is it called? Dead Parts.
Unknown parts on them. Yeah. And
it's, it's basically the same show,
but this one he has more control
of and it's, now it's on CNN.
It's got a bigger budget.
But the,
the show,
the one that he had on the travel channel
was the first experience that I had
ever had with chefs.
A guide knew that I liked good food and
I kind of understand that it takes a
special person to make good food,
but I'd never understood how
intensive the processes are,
how creative the processes. And, I mean,
he explored some really
boutique restaurants where
these guys grow their own
food, hunt their own meat. And
there's a, there's one place in Spain,
I think it was, I think it's closed. It
was called El Bulli where this guy was,
this head chef was this legendary guy who
brought in all these amazing chefs and
they would just create these
fucking intense works of art,
these small plate works of art that
were just so unique and inspiring.
Maybe want to write jokes, you know,
maybe may, maybe want to expand my comedy.
Right.
Retain, you know, you know, but at the
same time there, the, as as intense,
they are about those unique dishes. You'll
also catch a eating a bowl of popcorn.
Yes. Yeah. Why not? Well,
Bourdain's a big one on street food.
He loves like street Tacos
and sure. I mean, why not?
Don't be pretentious about it. It's
all about the, the full spectrum of
is Kinda like that film.
Um, perfume, what is that?
Uh, was it dubbed? Yeah.
Um, intense. Uh,
a movie about this guy that's
got a perfume, a story of murder,
I think is what the title is, right?
Is that right? Yup. Um, and it,
it starts going off about this
child who was born in poverty, um,
that,
uh,
what had such an incredible sense of
smell. He didn't differentiate, uh,
bad smells from good smells.
He just could smell everything.
And he was very good at like deciphering
all these, all these smells there,
but you know, so it's, uh, I'm an,
I'm not going to spoil it for you.
You get to see it. I'm not going to watch
it. It's awesome. It, it really good.
This is the trailer right here.
It's pretty awesome. It's uh,
it's pretty intense.
Dude's a creeper. A creeper. It's got to,
I think it's got Dustin Hoffman.
I read about a polar bear today that they
train or a dog they trained to smell.
If polar bears are pregnant.
You have to just
to stop and think of that.
How specific is that dog trained to
tell if polar bears are pregnant?
So it likes, is it just
kind of sit around? Uh,
almost like a firefighter
kind of went through a fire.
That's powerful.
Ooh,
good movie. You recommend
that. Okay, I'll get something.
I got to fly to Kentucky tomorrow. No
threat. Throw that bitch on the laptop.
It's pretty fun. I,
you'll enjoy it. If you
don't enjoy it, I'll recommend out of
them. What would you on enjoy? Okay.
It sounds like a good deal.
A dog that can smell if
a polar bear is pregnant,
they say that the best way to describe
how good a dog's nose is is skunks.
Cause that's the one time where
we can smell parts per million.
A skunk is so the,
the,
the scent is so strong that we actually
can catch that sent from blocks and
blocks away. Yeah. Very much like
a dog can smell things. Okay.
Yeah. Which is pretty
interesting way of, uh,
exploring the idea because otherwise it
seems like intangible. Well, when, yeah,
when,
uh,
we have have Lena around the Arizona and
as soon as I have on the come anywhere
near the vineyard or near their
yard, the dog is up. Yeah.
He could smell them already.
Well, they're scary animals.
Not even in the yard yet and there
they're up in what they can tell.
Those are freaky things,
man.
Do you ever seen when they hunt Hava
Lenas it's pretty intense. There's,
they're the one of the few animals that
when you call them, they come running.
Like if you make a sound
like an injured animal,
they don't sort of like
sneak around or try to start.
They come running straight towards that
sound and then they realize there's a
person there that Yikes, they haul it
and turn around and run the other way.
But they supposedly it tastes great.
It tastes like very much like a wild pig.
Yeah. But you, what's one
of those situations where
if you don't, if you don't
feel dressed them properly,
uh,
they've got some weird glands
will just ruin all the meat.
He cut the wrong gland and it's done.
Yeah. Probably the tarsal glands. Yeah,
they're stinky fucking animals.
But they have to be, man,
they have to be wild hardy bitches.
They live in out there in the desert man.
There's, that's what they look
like just to like a freaky small,
wild pig looking thing.
And I keep,
people keep telling me
that they're actually more,
had more in common with a rat pig.
Yeah. But that looks like a tree.
That looks like a fucking pig to me.
Yeah. It looks like a pig to me too.
But I guess a rack kind of looks
like a pig too. They just small.
I have no desire to eat them, so they
must not be a pig because I love a bacon.
They apparently tastes really good.
They taste very much like pig.
Wild pig is supposed to be
the best I've never had.
There's got to be silenced in La.
This serves Hev Lena someplace
in La has to serve out her.
Avalina you would assume.
Let's find out.
I bet it's really hard to get
commercial. Have Alina though. You know,
you'd have to hire hunters
to go out and get it for you.
And what kind of a supply could you
actually get? What's that place?
It's up in uh, like Malibu.
It's like that kind of, um,
game restaurant. Oh yeah, the
saddle peak lodge I wouldn't have,
yeah, I have it. I don't think
so. I was there recently.
They have like elk and venison and
things along those lines. And Pheasant,
I don't think they have Havoline
is pretty, that's pretty freaky.
You got to go to Lake New Mexico
to get a house call and say
step up. Yeah. Call Him and
say, listen man, I'll come in.
If you have Havalina Tako who have a
polar bear periods sniffing dog steaks and
have Lena,
there was a website that was selling
exotic meat from animals like lions.
They were selling like lion meat
and also at Catalina Cantina.
What does that sit down in Arizona.
Oh,
did they really sell Havalina
there though? Probably not. No,
that's like a Friday's Tgi Fridays.
You know,
in Arizona it's more like a Thursday.
I said they take a day off really more,
a little more laid back. A little longer
weekend. It's hot. Yeah, it's hot.
It's fucking the summertime man.
And then you get that Sheriff Arpaio,
Dick Wad that sheriff,
you know who that guy is?
You don't know who sheriff Arpaio is.
You guys have the most controversial
sheriff in the entire country. Uh,
John Down South around Tucson.
He's the guy that puts everybody in
pink underwear and a pink jumpsuits and,
and it has the men stay outside and
tense, no air conditioning. It's bad.
Make some work.
Um,
it sounds like it sounds like college.
I think it's more,
there's more but fucking than regular
college. Oh, okay. I think it's, uh,
he's just this really controversial,
conservative a guy.
Yeah.
I'd see the photo of these guys that
he puts him in this a clean and sober.
I guess he had Mike Tyson, uh, in
one of those apparently resting to,
and didn't get knocked the fuck
out. No, I mean, he's pretty,
pretty insulated by the
time you get to him.
Quite a few people with guns in the way.
It's true.
But he's a famous for sort of
representing Arizona, you know,
and then we get a lot of,
we have a lot of those people,
like those governor that Jan brewer chick,
she's one of the few people that I've
ever seen like give a debate where I was
like, hmm, I could be a governor.
I was listening to her talk and
I was like, I could do that job.
I can definitely beat her. George Bush
wasn't enough. You had to wait to her jam.
Bruce? No, I don't think I could
be president of too many skeletons,
but I could be a governor.
I can tell you they'll let you get
away with a few skeletons if you're a
governor. Sure. I mean, none of them are
bad and I've never done any real crimes.
I don't have any bodies or
anything like that as Ooh drawer,
actionable wisdom said a few
things were sort of two things.
Mark come back to haunt me,
but nothing,
but I watch her give debates and I'm like,
oh, this is hilarious. And then she won.
I mean I watched a debate
where she was just,
and then you realize you to be
stumped. Yeah, it really is.
I can beat this check I'll have to
do is prepare a little saint hard.
How the fuck did she win? How was she
your governor? How is that? I don't know.
You didn't vote for it to do.
All right.
How far away is the a place
that you trained Jujitsu?
Is it a, a real town? Yeah,
it's uh, in Cottonwood, so it's small,
you know,
small Dojo,
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu.
It used to be one point in time.
It was super hard to
find a good Jujitsu jam.
Guys would buy like VHS tapes and train
each other and now it's so amazing.
There's so many, there's, there's guys in
Prescott now, there's guys in cottonwood.
I think that might be guys in Sedona,
but there's definitely guys in
Prescott and cottonwood. Well,
Arizona itself is a huge hotbed
for mixed martial arts. You know,
you've got the lab, which is where
a Benson Henderson comes from.
John crouches place. Then you've
got a power MMA, which is where,
you know Erin Simpson, CB. Dot. The way
a lot of like big name MMA fighters.
A lot of guys come out of as a mega
tons. The studios there. Yup. Yup, Yup,
Yup. Yeah, it's a, it's
really interesting how, um,
that sport has a,
it's opened up the door for not,
not be even people that
want to compete in MMA,
but people that are just interested
in exploring martial arts. You know,
the amount of legit martial arts schools
is probably at an all time high in this
country now.
Yup. Yeah, I would, yeah, I would have,
I would agree that I just got back from
a training with my friends in St Louis
that was
hurt my wrist.
Derp derp how much training do you do
when you're on the road? Do you like,
it's harder, way harder.
I mean, if, you know,
if we have a day where we
can go in and train and, uh,
we have like a nice day off or a
day off, you know, two days off,
then I can risk it. But,
you know, to go in and just,
there's what time, you know, when would
you do it on, right. On a show day,
there's just no way.
But you've been involved
in one form or another,
at least peripherally in martial arts
for a long fucking time now. Right.
You know, I saw a photo of you with Bj
Penn back when he was like a purple belt.
I got,
I got injured in like 2003
or 2002 actually before that.
And then I just kind of compounded and
then I had to just stop around 2000.
That was the back thing, right? Yeah. This
is what a, I got drawn out of my blood.
This is the what pushed me over
the top and gave me the flu.
I'm gonna pull this up for you.
You see this fucking ridiculous amount
of blood they sucked out of my body.
That's, yeah, Jello shots. Let's go. Uh,
that's what they take and heat up and
then spin in the centrifuge and I'll let
you know how it works out.
But I've been dealing with a,
a back injury for the past
altogether for about four,
four or five years now, but pretty
bad over the last year and a half,
on and off and started getting numbness
in my hands and things along those lines
where I was realizing that my nerves
are getting in impeded and smushed.
And I realized I had to
do something about it.
So I don't have any of the
symptoms anymore. But, uh,
this is supposed to do an amazing job
here. Yeah, it did in Santa Monica. Okay.
Well they do it in Germany
and that's where I was going.
Dana white has been going over there for
it. He has [inaudible] disease, which is,
uh, something to do with a in the, the,
the inner ear and it makes
Vertigo and tinnitus.
He gets like this ringing in his ear and
you're like literally can't stand up,
loses his balance.
But the guy who developed
this process in Germany, uh,
trained a bunch of other doctors and
now they're doing it in Santa Monica as
well. So I just went in today,
you're my Guinea pig then I'm in,
I just got the first, uh, injections
today, but I'm with Ya. Old dudes
back problems.
So I look,
so one thing that does soc about, about
trainings that your, you know, your body,
your vehicle,
it's not a race car to assist flesh,
just in general wrestling and Jujitsu.
It's just,
it's just brutal. It's not, you know,
it's not just going into a
gym and there's a, there's a,
there's a direction at this weight
machine moves and that's it. Yeah,
it's every direction.
That's why it's so critical to find
good training partners. You know?
It's just like we were talking
about cultivating good friends,
cultivating good training
partners is another one.
Like there's a few guys had a 10th planet
Jiu Jitsu that I know I can count on
to not spazz out to be tested.
And I'm still learning that,
you know,
even even now it's like I'm so used to
my wrestling background where it's like
go, go, go and I'm having to go slow,
slow,
slow.
Yeah. If you ever watch like
really high level guys go at it.
One of the more fascinating aspects of
it is it looks like there's very little
effort being applied,
you know,
especially when they're sparring a little
bit more. So when they're competing,
when they're competing, you
know, they're going after it.
But when they're sparring,
like a lot of times these guys
are just sort of rolling around.
It seems like they're flowing
like walk, walk, walk, walk.
Never give the guy a position where
he could sprint to the finish line,
always make him that he's got four or
five steps before he can sprint because a
regular person won't see the difference
between that, between the, the,
the what it looks like casual rolling.
And even though they're casually rolling,
he's always going to be two or three spots
away from the finish line. It's chess.
Yeah, it really is. And that's
something that I've found, uh,
like we were talking about things
that inspire you creatively. I,
I get inspired by people who have
a lot of discipline for Jujitsu.
I get inspired by people that are, you
know, constantly creating and, and,
and putting,
putting a new slant on that in that
Jujitsu is very much an art form.
I mean,
the word martial art,
it seems wrong to people that don't
participate in it. Like the word art,
it seems like the wrong thing.
But when you do it,
you realize like if you watch it and
you see if you have an aptitude for you
understand it and you see what's going
on and then you watch someone's really
good at it, it becomes beautiful. And then
it does become an art. It is something,
not just an art as far as like
something creative but in art,
like as in something
visually beautiful and very,
very inspirational man,
I think.
And it's also another one of those
things that I think like creating wine,
like putting together a band,
like putting together a comedy act,
like writing a novel, like these things
that we do when we put our, our, our,
our thoughts and our creativity
into something, they sort of, they,
they don't just exist in a vacuum,
but they sort of enhance all the
other aspects of our life too.
I agree. Yeah. And just in
general, I mean there's the,
just that whole just physical aspect of
making the blood go through your system
and then being in shape, you just
start, you start thinking more clearly.
You're more creative. Uh, you can Kinda,
you can kind of solve puzzles better
if you're just, if you're, if I notice,
if I just, I just needed a break.
I just started slouching off.
It starts to kind of compound. If they
don't get back into something, walking,
running, no job. Do you ever fuck
around with Yoga? A little bit. Yeah.
I need to do more. That's one of those
things that I just feel like it's the,
that's the,
that's the on the to do list that I just
keep being embarrassed about having to
put it on the next to do list.
Yeah.
That's one of those things that everybody
always says to, I need to do more yoga.
I, we talk, we talk about Yoga and, Oh
God, I need to do, it's, it's a, it's an,
it's an, it's an absolute
embarrassing reality. I ha it's,
I have to do more yoga. Yeah. I, uh,
couple good DVDs,
so I slapped in the laptop on the road.
It's a very satisfying thing to do,
to work out in a hotel room completely
alone and do just a whole yoga class
through a laptop.
When you get through it,
it's a real feeling of accomplishment
because I could have just ate Doritos and
watch TV and stuff is what I
did last night.
Yeah,
it was actually a Swedish fish. It wasn't
treatise Swedish fish. Those are rare.
When you have those nearby,
it's really tough to say no to them.
That's what I'm saying. Like,
Ooh, Swedish, I can pay,
I can do yoga or I can have
these. Well, you could do both.
That's where it gets hard.
I was out of town,
so you know when I'm in a hotel
out of town and my wife's mental,
wherever she is,
it's my opportunity to watch like all
the stupid movies that she just won't
watch while I'm around. Like what?
I watched that new a Riddick buoy.
I saw that.
I saw that with my daughter.
She was looking at me like, what the
fuck did you take me to say? I'm like,
I'm sorry. It's so awful to
watch the whole thing so bad.
The whole, yeah. It was one of the
worst moves laughing the whole time,
laughing at myself and knowing
that like she's probably laughing.
Knowing that it sucks
so bad and here I am.
I like watching the whole thing and
just laughing at myself for watching it.
The craziest thing is the first
one was really good, you know,
and I tried to explain that to my 17
year old after we saw it, which was
like the first one was good near dark.
It was a good fucking movie,
good scary science fiction movie.
But somewhere along the line, what
is this number? 34 as for I think,
I can't tell you how many
times I've watched chronicles.
Is chronicles good idle while
my wife doesn't think so.
There's something going on now, man
with science fiction movies where there,
there's so much CGI and they can get
away with doing so much on the screen
visually that I'm detached.
I'm not feeling like I went to see star
track the last star trek one into the
darkness, whatever the fuck
it was. And I was like,
this is just a bunch of things happening.
I have no connection at
all to any of these panels.
Pretty connected, but not bad.
Yeah.
But the last one was just like,
it's just a series of things
happening in front of you. Well,
you don't give a fuck. Right.
You know, it's just, they're,
they're, they're almost,
I get, well I guess, you know, it comes
down back to the art. Yeah. If you,
if you see somebody taking even a
mediocre script and just running with it,
you see when you see an
artist kind of ticking those,
being able to tell those stories too
where you just believe it. You know, I,
I don't know if I use this example
with you last time, but, um,
I just saw it again,
this a,
this season of sons of anarchy watching
Kim coats fully get an erection over.
I'm Walton Goggins and drag and
it's just, you know, it's, you know,
a while and God says fake tits
and he's, you know, like a mass,
cause he's trying to get
his son back and you know,
the lipsticks all smeared
and, and like, you know,
Kim Coates is trying to figure out how
he's going to date this dude. He's just,
it's just such an awkward,
but they completely sell it like,
like all the way you're,
you're convinced like that.
He loves her and it's like not a her,
it's Walton Goggins and with fake boobs.
There you go.
That's hilarious. I haven't given
a choice to try to find a shot of,
of Kim coats staring at staring
at him. Her, it's an incredible,
and now as he supposed to be a
transsexual or transgender or trends,
uh, I think, I think, uh,
I think she still has her previous
equipment but also has tits.
So are the tits, those are their
implants or their hormones? Implants.
I Dunno. Hmm. They don't
specify. No, probably. They
don't really say, I don't think.
Yeah.
The only thing they'll throw you off
with those things is the dimple size and
jet men generally don't have the
right nipples for boobs like that.
So when you see him and they
used to be a man, can I go,
just trying to give you advice, Bro.
Thanks. Get Dark. Don't get sensitive.
If she gets weird trend transgender
communities. Therefore you,
he sound like you've done a lot of
research on I have, unfortunately,
I'm fascinated
by a gender identity.
I'm fascinated by people who
decide that they think you'll love it
and you can see why they brought their,
he's, he's got his arm
around her now. Wow. Awesome.
Um, what'd, you can see why when it
first came up, they were just using this,
this tranny to blackmail a dude.
And even in that scene,
the character tig,
Kim's like just was so
distracted by what was like,
they were supposed to just be
doing this job and he's just,
he was so fascinated with this person
and you could see why the writer put it,
put it back in to a later season because
anybody who's watching that show and
bring her back, that was
awesome. And now he's now oh wow.
Boom. Oh Wow. How did they do that?
So that's the dude from the shield. Yeah.
Yeah. Oh, that's hilarious. Yeah. And a,
and a justified, I'm missing
out. I need to start.
He's one of my favorite actors,
but I think he's a great actor
that they can act his ass off.
He was fantastic in the shield to
are they on like season? What season?
Like six or seven. Yeah. I can't catch up
now. It's too late. It's just daunting.
It's too much once. Yeah.
I Dunno. I can't, I don't,
do you watch anything else on TV? The
stupid no I cause I, I mean I watch,
I watch all kinds of stupid shows but
I'm always looking at like if I find out
there's an actor that I like in a thing,
I want to see how they're dealing with
the puzzle they've been dealt. That's,
that's my, that's kind of
like why I'm even watching it.
I'm just want to see the craft of or you
hear a rumor of like watch this fucker
unravel. Like cause you
can, he had some, he slips.
This particular actor is having some
issues so you'll want to watch the show to
watch his feet can see if he could get
a whiff of the crazy coming off them.
Like what do you mean? Like, yeah,
maybe they are getting into pills or
something and kind of looking just seemed
just trying to hold it together.
And you can also like two episodes later,
there's like a new character that could
potentially take over that person's
position. Oh, that's fine. I think in a
building it into the script to go. Okay,
so you add the background,
you have a little flavor.
Yeah. Just to see how they're,
just see how that's gone. Well
that's a, that's a common issue.
Especially the pills. Yeah. It's poor
fucks. Yeah. And it's hard to want the,
you know,
I have a lot of friends that are,
that go through that
kind of stuff and it's,
that's one of the hardest things
to get out of your system.
You'd probably rather,
you know,
you're better off trying to get off heroin
because the pills just go deep. Yeah.
When the pills essentially our heroin,
heroin, I mean that's what they are.
They're, they're their opiates and they
leave a lot. They do do damage. Yeah.
Nature damage. And they prescribed
them like they're giving out free gum.
I mean it's,
it's amazing how many
people are on prescription
painkillers in this country and
how many of those painkillers or
opiates and how many of those people are
addicted to those
opioids. So we're, we're,
we're fucking weird when it comes
to that man. Without a doubt.
That's of the most disturbing aspects
of our society. The uh, amount
of pills that people consume.
No, it's a, it's dark. And
when you see someone, yeah,
they had a cardiac care can I
started right? Kind of, you know,
like about a generation
before us with the Valium
[inaudible] sudden sure. Rolling
Stones Song. Mother's little helper.
Yeah. She goes running for
the shelter. Yeah. That's a,
that's when they first found out that
you could live a shitty life and,
and get through it with some sort of
medication and just medicate yourself and
dull the angst and dull the,
the desire for,
to free yourself from this fucking hell
she existence and, or just do something.
You could definitely do that
to just go do something. Yeah.
I wonder how long it's going to take
society figured out as a whole to,
that'll be a thing of the past without,
yeah.
Expecting to be compensated for it.
Just do it because you want to do it.
Yeah. No, that's great
advice for some people.
I think they have a hard time finding
something that they actually enjoy doing
too.
Well you're so kind
addition to it wants stuff and to have,
you know,
like the fluff around it from
the glory days or whatever.
He forget that just,
you know,
work harder for less to just enjoy your,
what you do
you have children now? I have,
I have a son. He's 17, 18.
What does it like, like
seeing someone who, you know,
you created who's about to enter
into this crazy world as a,
an an independent,
I mean it's essentially a,
on his way to being a man
is 18 is basically at the
launching block of manhood.
Well, you know, he's
way smarter than I am,
so there is no, I don't have any
worries about him finding his way.
He's intuitive. He's um, uh, personable.
He is good at understanding
social dynamics,
but he's extremely smart. You know, he
wants to go into a chemistry and biology,
so, but he's also an incredible
cello player, so, wow. Um,
he'd got a scholarship to play cello
for a performance of high school, uh,
for cello. And so, but he's not going to
pursue cello for his college. He just,
that's just an extra thing he does and
he rocks at it. So I don't have any,
I guess part of it is when you,
my parents are,
my dad is just a very active person,
very smart man and uh,
and healthy. And so when
I see him, when you know,
when you kind of know where you are,
where you've been,
you know where you're going.
So I have feeling that's just
having my son see what I did,
see what my, my dad has
done. He's, he has in a way,
he has a good compass. Um,
good navigation skills.
Yeah. I mean, the only
concern that I have,
the big concern is that children today
are up with so many more variables than
we ever did and also much more potential
for quicker learning because of the
Internet. And, and with that, again, more
potential, more and more possibilities,
more variables, more things to
think about. It's like more,
more that could potentially
be overwhelming. Right.
And I, and I think most kids are,
I think there's, you know this,
my father was a high school teacher and
by the time he retired it was basically
because um,
they kind of pushed him out to get into
new person who wasn't going to question
the curriculum.
He was very,
he was very adamant about making the
people who came into that classroom.
You had to make an effort in his classroom
to pass the class. You couldn't coast.
It wasn't anything,
it was like a multiple choice question.
You were answering the questions
and you had to know the material.
Then you had to be on time. You had
to put in over the course of the year,
you were also doing homework and coming
in with completed thoughts that were,
that counted towards your grades.
Then if you didn't complete all aspects
of that in his class, you didn't do well.
Yeah.
If there's any one thing that you can
in instill in a child that's going to
guarantee them a healthier existence
is an appreciation for work and a pure
appreciation for accomplishing things,
calm setting and accomplishing goals.
So,
so few kids are ever
indoctrinated into that,
that sort of the way of life.
No,
we didn't.
We didn't get to school unless he got up
at 6:00 AM and snow blowed the driveway
in the winter.
We weren't going to work.
Where'd you guys live? Boston. Michigan,
Michigan. Yeah. I lived in Boston.
Same.
Same sort of situation.
Yeah. You know, our driveway
was almost a quarter mile long,
so we didn't snow blow the driveway.
We weren't getting to the main
road that was hopefully plowed
a quarter mile of snow
blowing. Holy Shit. Well,
luckily it was snow blowing
and not shoveling. Yeah,
mother fucker. Yeah. A quarter.
And you're dealing with
some serious snow up there.
Yeah. Cause it's on the Lake Michigan
side, so you get a lot of, oh wow.
It's fucking cold. My uh, senior year,
we had seven days of school in January.
What's that? That's hilarious. Lizard
would hit on Sunday or Monday and boom.
Done Til Thursday. Tell me though,
how awesome were snow days growing up?
That's one thing. People
in California, Arizona Spo,
mountain dew and red licorice,
I used to look out that window
and if I saw like a foot on,
on the car outside park,
I'll be like, fuck yeah.
And then you would call that number and
it was a number. They would, you know,
they would,
they would list off the different towns
where school was cancelled and if they
got to Newton,
I would go fuck yes.
Who was just this huge radius the day.
Yeah.
I was a beautiful thing.
And it was also the thing that I really
appreciate lot about a grown up in a
really fucking cold place despite,
uh,
on top of learning that,
you know,
there's a good to having really
fucking cold snowy days. And that's,
you really appreciate the sunny
days. A different vigor, you know,
seasons. Yeah. But there's also the quiet,
there was a weird quiet when everything's
covered in snow that I don't think
anybody will ever appreciate
unless they experience it. Oh yeah.
It's amazing when you're out there
and it's like a full on snow storm and
there's just a foot and a
half of snow on the ground.
The trees are covered with snow.
You don't hear shit.
It's this weird eerie rigging silence.
Yeah. Cause it's a different, you
know, if it's, if it's a rainstorm,
of course you're hearing the rain.
Yeah. Just that floating snow,
big chunks coming down. It's almost like
an incredible sound barrier. Yeah. Yeah.
Absorbs everything. And you're
just like, you're such a like,
like an isolation tank.
Yeah.
You hear like every now and then you
hit a car and the distance trying to get
out of a driveway.
Right.
Ooh.
Or your name and long ago
fucker wold start. Yeah.
I grew up in this area that was across
the street from a river. And uh, we, we,
it was a fairly rural area.
And um,
this a giant park and the river was
across the street from my house and the
street was a pretty steep and every time
it would snow or especially if it would
rain the street would become a hockey
rink and I would watch cars drive down the
hill and just right when
they got to my house,
that'd be losing control into your room,
bouncing off curbs.
I F I think there's something
to learn about that.
Then there's something about dealing with
weather that I think is healthy for a
person.
Healthy for your character.
Well I haven't driven a
car in snow and you know,
decades or for any length of time,
but in Jerome we get snow in the winter
and it's amazing to me how people just
cannot drive in it. Yeah. We get it
every year, you know, a little bit,
sometimes a lot more. But having to, like,
I immediately just get in my jeep and I
go up to a point in the town where it's
the problem spot and just park and wait
because there was somebody that can't
get up the hill or around the bend because
I just can't understand not to slam
on the gas.
So you parking weight to help people?
Yeah cause cause they're good because,
well I'm helping, you know I'm not,
don't you know I'm not to,
here we go stuff at one of those
ones where they do the crash thing.
Not because I'm like some
kind of, you know, helping,
helping hand type guy did this.
Oh Jesus Christ,
the guys getting [inaudible].
The cool thing about though
about accidents and the
snow is they just sort of
bump into each other and slide around.
There's no one's glued onto the ground.
So it's the same kind of impact.
Right.
Well you know I,
I go up there to help them out
just because I know if I don't,
there's going to be like 20 cars behind
them. They can't get where they're going.
So it's just like, it's just more a
matter of like bringing a plunger to the,
to the shit show.
This is a certain amount
of camaraderie too, when,
when things like that happened snow and
people have to help push people's cars
at a spots and things long.
That's another thing that people don't,
don't deal with an la, the
lack of weather in La. It's,
I think one of the reasons why people
are so cocky because they never get
humbled. This is your
fucking rain here. You know?
I remember after the
earthquake in [inaudible] 94
is just when I moved here in
93 whatever it was,
I moved here right after that happened
and I remember people were so nice,
they were so humble. It was
a weird thing. It was like,
it brought people
together for a little bit.
So that was a strange experience to,
yeah. You know, I was all, you know,
Steve Martin, the jury out in the backyard
with my dogs in front of me. Like,
you know,
like hearing the trees just like
creaking around at all the car alarms,
like a symphony of car alarms going off.
It was crazy.
Like hearing the glass shattered
everywhere. Freak me out.
Yeah, I missed it. I came, I
came right after it happened,
but I got caught in one
of the bigger aftershocks.
I was in an apartment on North
Hollywood and my apartment moved around.
The best way I could describe it
as if it was a refrigerator box.
It just went side to side,
side to side side.
It's like it was made of nothing
and I was just going holy shit
by like, uh, um, Lankershim
Vineland and camera. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. That's what I was,
that's where I lived right behind the
blockbuster there by the Firestone. Yeah.
I was like, uh, just uh,
I guess it would be just
east of Laurel Canyon,
like deep down, like more park.
I was, I'm more park. Yeah.
You weren't that you weren't that far
from me and know that fucking thing
outside nude with my dog as a Merkin
freaked the fuck out.
Yeah.
And there was that feeling about like
Los Angeles then where people were
humbled, you know, they were like
a little nicer to each other.
And I felt that again in New York right
after September 11th, I remember a,
I lived in New York in the
early nineties. And then, uh,
when I went back to New York, I
remember, uh, like California,
I'm thinking that people in California
were like a lot more mellow and nicer
than people in New York and people in New
York always had that sort of hard edge
to it. But when I went after
September 11th, that edge was gone.
There was this warmth to people in New
York and a friendliness that I hadn't
ever experienced before. I was like,
this is really interesting. I'm like,
there's a real tangible,
positive impact that this tragedy has
had is that people are appreciating each
other more people are silver lining.
Yeah. The, I think, you know,
it's almost like people need perspective.
They need to see negative to positive.
You need to see those shitty Michigan
winters to appreciate a good summer day in
California. Every day is a great summer
day. Today was a great summer day.
It's fucking November 4th it's
82 degrees outside. You know,
we're, we're a little spoiled when
it comes to that. People need nature.
They need to see it and you know,
fucking rainstorm,
just kick your ass just to let you know,
like it's fucking thing can
come down on you. And anytime
I have no point, that's where it ends.
I liked it. It's true though, right?
I think that's the one curse. It's
almost like being born rich, you know,
you ain't never have to deal with
adversity in California. There's a,
a lack of appreciation for the fact
that you're actually on a planet,
that you're actually a part of nature.
You know, just, there's no seasons here,
so you don't really get the
chance to see that change.
So what a perfect place to put the,
the factory of all things fake.
You know?
I mean,
if you really wanted to think about a
great way to fuck up a culture, right?
You know,
just take a spot where the weather never
changes and then put cameras on people
and pretend they're interesting.
Pretend they're amazing.
Give them lines to say that the winds too
fucking stupid. Oh yeah. Convinced them.
Give them cocaine.
Give them tons of money for pretending.
Confuses the shit out of everybody and
make it so that they get in line first at
a clubs. Everybody lets them in. They,
they throw velvet carpet down and they
walk on them and everybody cheers.
Confused the fuck out of everybody.
Right. This is the spot. And by the way,
it never rains and it never rains.
Rain and Arizona this year did it.
Yeah. And a lot of good rain. Yeah.
Arizona doesn't get much
props, man. It's not like when,
when people talk about the
cool spots in this country,
Arizona doesn't get much props
unless you're on, you know,
unless you're on a vision quest,
unless you're on a vision quest.
Let's look for some solid payoti.
Yup.
Some San Pedro cactus and a
good sweat lodge. That's pretty,
you try to find your spirit. That's
for the kids. That's for the kids.
I don't fuck with that.
Payoti I've never fucked with Payoti.
I've heard mixed mixed reviews.
Um,
hi. You know, maybe, maybe, uh,
I had a balls friend who had a
good experience on it. Oh yeah.
Did he look like you?
A little bit. Not then.
Not quite then. Yeah. I'm but more of
a mushroom guy myself, mushrooms and,
and tryptamines. But a, hey,
snub my nose. It no pod.
This pod is a weird one too, because you
can actually own legally own the cactus.
Not just own it,
but you can buy it at hardware stores.
You'd go to Home Depot and get San Pedro
Cactus and I'm pretty sure that's how
you make it. Right. I
don't know. I was with,
I was with some indigenous
people who invited me into their
ceremony, so it was quite,
quite a special moment. Right?
Yeah.
I have no personal experience,
but I have one friend that did it and
said that he was in an apartment building
and he was listening to people talk that
were easily five blocks away and he was
listening to every word out
of their mouth. And he could,
he couldn't believe that he could hear it,
but he was absolutely sure that
he could hear it. God bless him,
God bless pot
and woke up with one of those orange
cones stuffed in his ear. Good.
No, he woke up trying to figure out
whether or not it was a dream. You know?
That's, uh, that's the problem with
those hallucinogen is experiences,
even if it's an incredible
beneficial experience,
there's that wrestling match or were
you like, was it real? What was that?
And I'm trying,
I try to get people to look at
psychedelic experiences as this way.
Like whether it was real
or whether it wasn't real,
the experience was exactly the same.
So if you took mushrooms and truly did
go to another dimension and communicate
with ultimate knowledge and,
and,
and then then and tune into
the love of the universe,
tune into the frequency of,
of life and of,
of progress and,
or whether it happened in your mind,
it's still the same experience.
Right?
And it, but you know, I would, if
people are going to do those things, uh,
I think it goes back to what you were
talking about before about understanding,
you know, preparation for this thing
you're going to do. Having respect for it,
to having absolute respect for it and
understand what you're getting into and
understanding when you get, you know,
wherever you go, uh, understanding,
uh,
how to handle it.
Just to kind of us finding us a center
in yourself that can you kind of handle
what it is you're seeing and try
to stay out of fear in a moment.
Stay away from fear and just
to, you know, just prepare.
If you're going to do those kinds of
things. Just prepare for the journey,
prepare for the journey
and learn how to let go.
And if you are going to do those things,
do it hopefully with somebody who knows
what the fuck they're doing because if
you start messing with that stuff and
neither one of you know what you're both
going to be under that, that, that fog of
fear. Right? You're both going to be tech.
But if one guy's like, dude,
trust me, I've been here before,
I know how to get out of this neck of
the woods. Right. Going to be okay.
All right. How much benefit have you had
personally from psychedelic experiences?
Um, I didn't, you know, I didn't
really, uh, do a lot of it. Um,
compared to people that I knew that
did a lot of it and didn't make it out,
didn't make it out. He has a
lot of guys, you know, you know,
you've met them and you've met
those kind of people that just,
they didn't quite make it out and
it's Kinda twisted him for, for life.
How many people do you know like
that? Dozens. We'll, yeah. Holy Shit.
Just, you know, they're just
not, they're never going to,
just because of the whole nature of how
it breaks down some of those barriers
between your left and right brain.
Um,
just metaphorically, you know, just, uh,
just how you think about
your creative processes.
They can never quite get their feedback
on the ground to understand what it,
what it means to actually, uh,
do a thing rather than just,
you know,
imagine a thing.
So,
you know,
dozens of people like that and wouldn't
know what was it was a lego series of
trips or was it like, did just did too
much, too much, too much, too long.
Just lived in that world for too long.
Yeah. That is, it didn't prepare again,
doesn't prepare for what they
were going to do. And See,
and Mckenna always had the best
advice when it came to psychedelics.
Large doses. Infrequently.
Right, right. And, and prepare,
prepare and don't do it all the time.
Do it and then process,
figure out what,
what can you get out of this yet
again, it's contrast you whatever you,
whatever it, whatever journey you took,
even if not on the psychedelics, see
if it, if it's like just some tire,
you're going to go for a month
to be silent in some, you know,
some spiritual place and
introspection and you know,
do a fast or whatever. You don't want to
do what you don't want to do that like,
you know,
12 months out of the year that doesn't,
they don't have any contrast
with anything. Just go do
it, get intense about it,
prepare for it before you go and then B,
and then be ready to take a while to come
out of it when you are coming back and
then you live your normal life.
Do you feel like you creating wine or
when you're putting together a DVD or when
you,
when you take on a project that you're
kind of on a journey like that as well?
But absolutely.
Yeah.
Everything, everything that uh,
yeah, everything that I've done this,
there's been some element of
preparation attached to it.
It's not something I just dive into
and then every time those
things are accomplished,
there's this feeling of
reinforcement of the process.
Yeah, I mean you, you know,
everybody has a way to check themselves
into thinking they're right or you know,
kind of consistently put up particular
process and to get some results back that
reinforces the behavior. But you
know, aside from that, if he just,
if you're just preparing a properly that
there's definitely a satisfaction from,
you know, coming from, you know, even
even the happy accidents along the way.
Things you learned that you didn't
think you were going to learn stuff.
That was actually a challenge
that he hadn't prepared for it,
but you managed to get through.
Those are the kinds of things that
really kind of make those results a
satisfying.
Do you intentionally seek inspiration
like through books or through
documentaries or anything? Not
intentionally, but just, you know,
I'll, I'll be reading a
book or an article seeing
a film and somebody will use a word that
resonates on some level and I go write
the word down.
Then I might build something on that word.
So it could be, it could be two years
from now that I'd come back to that word.
Right?
So just following your own curiosity or
interests and that eventually leads you
to it
ration, right? I mean, if you're,
if you're, you're into, you know,
physics and geometry in general chemistry,
there's those Thursdays structures
that are already there in terms of the,
the relationships between a numbers
and shapes and angles and, and, uh,
you know, just molecules. Um, and they're,
and they're very similar,
uh,
in respect to just the
emotional experiences, uh,
just life experiences, even just the Jira
and journey from, you know, an infant to,
uh, an elderly person. There's a whole,
there's very common angles and structure
and a commonality between those
experiences that can be,
can resonate.
So if I see a word that for some reason
resonates with me at the age of 35 or
40,
I write it down right away because most
likely there's some kind of a geometry
or residents with that word
that's speaking to me at this age,
in this stage of my life that
I should pay attention to.
So I'll write it down and I'll see you.
I'll explore it more to see if it is in
fact something that wouldn't be relevant
when I was 20 might not be relevant
when I'm 60 but it's relevant now, so,
so I'll look at it and I'll build on it.
Yeah, that's an interesting thing
about getting older and the,
the ideas that you come across,
these ideas are sort of cross referencing
with these other experiences that
you've had in your life up to this
point now and now. Now it resonates.
Now it makes sense.
Whereas at 21 it didn't mean a damn
thing to write a documentary and a guy
making Sushi when you were 21 would
be like, oh fuck am I watching? Right?
But when you're 41 it's like, oh, okay,
this guy is obsessed with this art.
There's something to this, right?
This guy's making swords. Look,
he's making a CS, folding the metal.
I watched a whole documentary on this
guy making traditional style Samurai
swords and the incredibly
intensive laborious process
involved in folding steel,
hammering it down, folding
it, hammering it down.
Fascinating Shit. Yeah. And that,
like everything else,
it's all just,
they're still skipping any steps
in the impossible. You know,
we weaving a rug properly,
you know,
making your own fucking clothes, uh,
of a thread. Yeah. Pulling, you know,
weaving threads together. Like some they
had to do that. That's what they did.
And you know, that's, there's,
there's, there's no other
way. I watched this, um, uh,
documentary on indigenous
tribes, Inuit tribes, uh,
creating fishing nets and that it would
take a year often to create one net a
fucking year. You better
have a couple already. Yeah.
You have to have a couple
already made and you know,
that's the way you're eating is the way
these fucking people are going to eat.
It goes back to those subsistence
shows I'm absolutely fascinated with.
Like there's this one that
I've been watching now, it's
called a life below zero.
And it's just these different families,
families or individuals who live up in
Alaska and then go from one to the next
and follow these people.
And this one,
a tribe that's a man and a
woman and the woman is a,
a native in you at woman.
And the man is a American from the lower
48 and they have children together and
you know,
like they've lost family members because
they fell through the ice and died.
And I mean this is like, this
is real shit. This woman who's,
they're walking across the ice and they're
like knocking holes into the ice to
make sure that it's deep enough for them
to walk and they're with their children.
And then they got to put this net
down underneath this ice and, and,
and feed it to each other and the other
side of the river and they're going to
catch fish.
And that's how they're,
they're all eating and there's no other
way to eat. And this is what they do.
And that's,
and that's their life.
And there's something about it that's
so fucking terrifying to you that just,
that just shut me down. That sounds
cold. Oh, it's fucking cold as shit,
man. Well, you know, this woman had
lost two family members. She lost a,
one of her sisters and I think one
of her brothers or maybe a cousin or
something like that, fell through. It was
just going to reach for a sweater. Yeah.
Yeah. It's, it's, it's wild shit man. But
to them, that's life. That's what they do.
That's what they're doing. That's,
that's, that's their existence.
Laughing while they're doing
it and everybody, I mean it's,
I guess people just
adapt and get used to it,
but there's also this like intense
spiritual connection with their food.
That way,
you know,
when they're pulling these fish out of
this water and the grabbing hold of it
and making sure it doesn't
fall back under the ice.
Like there's this intense connection
between this, this animal,
this, this creature that they just
caught, we don't really ever get.
And when they eat that animal,
there also this intense feeling of
satisfaction that goes with that,
that this substance living
very, very, very intense man.
Very intensive. Lost touch with that
because we have so much available to us,
you know, no matter where we look. Yeah,
we've got food, clothing, shelters,
pretty much readily available. We've
got a little lazy on that kind of stuff.
A lot lazy.
And I think it's a lot like what
we're talking about Los Angeles.
I mean Los Angeles too. Goddam
easy. There's no weather. No.
Whether it's simple,
go to the supermarket,
everything spelled out for you. Soft
life. Soft life creates soft people.
We got to figure out a way to fix
that. What's the way, dude? Um,
yeah,
reset. Do I, the only way I think is for
people to figure it out on their own,
to be inspired by people who are or
have figured that out. You know, the,
this marble is way smarter than we are.
So when it decides that
there's any even, you know, if,
if the kids get a little too cocky,
it'll,
it'll toss a few title ways or toss a
few meteors at it just to, just to reset.
It'll just reset and you'll go back to
having to figure out what to do with your
time,
not having your PDA.
I've always wondered if that's what
it did with the dinosaurs. If it,
if the earth looked at the
situation was like, those are big,
this is a mess. No one's going to figure
that out. No one's going to stop that.
They're stupid as fuck.
And they don't have to get smart.
They kill everything with their face
the way 50,000 pounds a piece. Right.
All right. You know what?
It's time to throw in a race
or their way. Yeah, I agree.
I think, I think that's probably the
case. Eventually we'll, you know,
something that you said how dependent
we are on I just everything digital and
electrical, just a simple,
natural, naturally occurring.
You know, electromagnetic pulse. We'll
just fucking ruined people's lives. Yeah.
One big fat solar storm that
erases everybody's Kendall. Yeah.
Don and go try find a book now. A hundred
years from now. Try Finding a book.
Yeah. Books. It'd be like records. It
was be like try and find vinyl today.
I many final do you Elliot? Everything
a few people do. Right? Yeah.
It's still pretty common.
We try to do every that every,
there are only a couple of things
I've released flustered with the,
haven't come out on vinyl to,
cause they were just digital,
but the pretty much everything
even. Yeah. Even the remixes we do,
we'll do final four to,
well there's a weird push now for not
even just a digital copy of something but
in the cloud to leave
everything in the cloud.
Like have you seen these
new Google chrome books?
They barely have a hard drive and
everything's in the cloud, right?
You're accessing your day. And I'm so
like, and I'm not, I'm not being like,
you know, grandpa kind of
know, hang onto his, you know,
his Beta Max or eight track
tapes or any of that that,
I mean, I honestly just like I keep,
when I download stuff off iTunes,
I have like a hard drive and I just
can't let go of the idea of like just
deleting it all and getting
it later when I want it.
Because I mean are we really going to
wash those CSI Miami episodes again?
Probably not.
But you feel better if they're sitting in
on that because I paid, I paid for him.
So why did you,
why don't I have them somehow near me?
I just am not willing to accept the
idea that everything's in the cloud.
And then it's secure either.
That's the other thing. I mean,
they want you to put all your photos
in the cloud and contacts in the cloud.
That stuff. I was like,
no. Yeah, I don't believe.
Think about it before you print
this photo out. Fuck you. What if I,
I'm not to have this photo.
If something
crazy happens like that and it's lost.
Yeah.
And also the,
the latest revelations that the NSA
tapped into the Google cloud and basically
access to everything that was
up there, which is a, you know,
Google's all pissed off, but come on,
you didn't see that coming, you know,
aren't you guys at the front of the line?
Don't, don't you know what's possible.
You seen that show yet? No.
What's that down? What is it?
It's everything you're talking about.
Like what's a show that just started,
you know, a couple of seasons ago and
like maybe it's third season or second,
third season. I think now Ben from
losses on it. Oh really? Yeah.
And it's all about him having been
the engineer, this computer that,
that was predicting, um, national threats.
And I think it takes everything. It takes
every camera it out with the access.
Any camera that has, you
know, that's in the system.
Here's the cameras on your phones,
every microphone.
And it puts together all of this data
looking at all the digital information and
uh, predicts like your national threats
and, and, but the, the trick, you know,
the whole trick of this story is like
nobody really knows about this thing at
all.
It's so,
so self contained than it
inserts this information into,
uh, and to studies or you
know, when they're looking at,
when we're looking at somebody
that was too weird. People that was Ben
from loft and Jesus does Jim Caviezel.
Yeah, the passion of the
Christ. That fucking nutty dude.
That dude thought he was Jesus. Who is
that Candy Alexander in the back? No Way.
Benjamin buttons. Mom. Oh,
okay. Wow. Pr. So good.
You recommend this,
right?
It was funny because like everything about
what the show is all of a sudden came
out with all this, you know, all
this NSA spying. They were like,
that's what they're doing already.
So this show is like kind of being
a cutting edge thing like on, Oh,
there's a supercomputer doing all this
stuff and they're like looking through
the cameras and there's gathering all the
information and all of a sudden you go,
none of their doing that right
now. Like this, this is not a,
this is not a stretch.
This is not a supernatural show.
This is like actually happening.
Well,
it went from being something that guy
like Alex Jones would rant and rave about
to the reality of the day and
it happened within like a month.
Right. You know, I mean everybody
sorta just realize like, oh shit.
Like everything you've ever
emailed somebody actually
is somewhere in a database.
That is the facts.
That's the world that we live in now.
This isn't science fiction anymore.
Does that,
that off color photo you sent me to,
I told you that wasn't real. What
do you, does that freak you out?
This is, what do you, what do you think
this is going to lead to this, this,
this does dissolving of
privacy. I Dunno. Um,
part of me says that I'm not, I'm not
really that important that it were,
that I'm too worried about anybody
looking at what I've got. Uh, you know,
the government like sifting through my
crap. There's nothing, there's nothing of,
yeah,
I agree in that personally,
but I also see it as something that's
very different than I think what,
what people are realizing.
I think everybody's worried about their
personal privacy and people were worried
about not just their personal privacy,
but the government being able to access
their personal privacy and to be able to
look into their photographs and read
their emails. And I get all that.
But I think that ultimately what
we're dealing with is a dissolving of
boundaries between people and information
and that it's going to be some,
there's going to be some
breakthrough one day,
whether it's some,
some ability to read minds or
some new way of connecting people,
some new way of separating boundaries
that's going to make this seem like a
joke,
that this is just basically one more
step in this neverending trend of a
dissolving of boundaries.
And I don't know. I don't,
you know, again, I don't know,
the other side of me is like, don't,
don't be looking at my emails. I don't,
you know, there's, that's, that's just my
personal stuff. And then you'd have no,
there's nothing of interest there
for you. I think I've done, you know,
I've done my part for society.
Why you're looking at my bunk.
Yeah. The, I think the, you know,
the people that are doing it too.
That's one of the weirdest things.
Like this Edward Snowden thing.
When it came out, it was, uh, they were,
they were trying to discredit him and
they're like this high school dropout,
Edward Snowden. And you're like, wait,
wait a minute man. Did you guys hire him?
Like you're, you're, you're
making fun of him now, but right.
Cause you're fucking employee,
man.
And he's telling everybody that he
had access to everybody's email,
not just encrypted,
but can actually fucking read them.
It wasn't just mad at metadata.
He could actually go and read your
emails and he was a high school dropout.
Right? Like who else is working
for you guys? Right? Like,
well, who gets these jobs?
How do they get these jobs?
Like the, the, the questions,
the questions are just leading to this,
this weird ultimate reality,
which is that the trend
seems to be across the line,
this dissolving of boundaries between
people and ideas and people and
information and then eventually everyone's
going to have access to everything.
It seems that that is,
and I just
think that that's, you know, I, I
get caught up in the idea of like,
well maybe this is part of some,
you know,
this might be just our tendency
to do things, you know,
this is what we do to control people.
You know, just through the ages, power,
you know, power wants more power. Uh,
but at some point you have to wonder like
was so is that, is that choice and the,
the dominant, you know,
whoever's in charge,
that's a tendency of uh, whatever
we are, whatever it makes us up.
Is that an extension of what,
again, going back to the marble,
is that what the marble wants in some way?
Is
that,
is that a,
is that consciousness just trying to
sort some things out and just take us to
the next step? Um, you know what
I mean? I, you know, I don't,
I have no answers to them. I'm just
saying, I still, I started asking,
I started asking those questions of like,
okay, so what's the, how, how would I,
you know,
if I was David Koresh,
how would I rationalize that
perspective? I mean those, so think,
but think like a crazy person who,
you know,
comes up with some awesome
rationalizations to justify
the actions and then try
to go the other way. Like, try to feed
like, you know, be more like the paranoid,
you know, opposite Defensive Brat,
you know, reasonably defensive, uh,
person who wants to be like,
wants to know why,
what the fuck do you
need to see in my emails?
I don't understand why
that's important to you.
I tried to look at it as someone who's
analyzing the human beings as a complete
alien, outsider looking at
us collectively as a group,
which is what we, we move as a group.
We act as a group and I, I would say,
well look,
here's this thing that works collectively
to make technology but thinks it's an
individual.
They all think that they're individuals,
but essentially all they're doing with
their manic desire to acquire goods and
did the acquire material possessions.
What they're really doing is just
pushing innovation because they need the
biggest, baddest, newest, craziest. They
constantly need the latest and greatest.
They're pushing for these innovations
and these innovations are constantly
within, you know, three,
four, five months.
The exponential increase of these
things is making every new step far more
powerful than any step before it.
And it's happening faster and faster and
faster. It's happening exponentially.
And I don't even think the
creatures even realize that
doing the, the, the, the,
the periods as Mckenna had put a thought
at the time periods between novelty and
novelty and normality or it's
like a home now. It's not even a,
it's not even a peak and valley anymore.
Yeah. Makenna described it
as a funnel that, you know,
if you spun a quarter around
the top of the funnel,
who took a long time to go
all the way around the circle,
but as it gets lower and lower,
it's getting faster and faster and faster
and faster until it reaches what he
thought would be a point
of ultimate novelty.
But he thought it was going to be the
December 21st, 2012 but think, you know,
he had, he's a a dude, you know,
he's a guy, right? You know,
at the end of the day it's brilliant.
As he was his fan,
fantastic as his mind was. He's still
just a person with an idea. And, you know,
we can, we grab ideas sometimes and
ride those bitches right into the rocks.
But you know,
if you look at those,
those, uh, this beautiful chaos, uh,
equations that kind of make those cool
kind of Paisley looking things and that
he looked really close and you see like,
oh,
the detail becomes fractals
Mandelbrot set. Yeah. So, you know,
if you look at that,
um,
when we get down to the bottom of that
funnel and you're looking close, there's,
there's a deeper funnel. It's just as
much detail as the funnel above it. So,
and he might ultimately have been right
in some sort of a way that December
21st, it might not have even been
that exact day, but that era,
the era between 2012 2013 which is the
era we're living in and experiencing
right now,
it might ultimately be this new
opening for this new future.
And this what we're talking
about where there's,
that's that TV show or the revelations
about the NSA that could be just the
first steps an opening up this new door
of perception, this new door of reality.
Right now we're living
in strange times man.
Yeah, totally. Yeah. Mixed
and it makes you know,
mix up person when I'm trying to write
songs or trying to make this wine or you
know, doing, you know, doing whatever, uh,
writing and doing comedy bits or whatever,
it almost makes it feel weird.
You almost feel kind of an odd like
self conscious way of like, what am I,
what am I doing?
Like you go to a show and you see like
the dude up there dancing around in front
of the people that are like watching
them dance around and look at you dancing
around.
Just feel so fucking weird.
Such a weird relationship of like,
like such a show until kindergarten
thing and when I like when you say a word
enough times, that was,
that sounds weird. Yeah.
That when I look at that and I think
about it like that, like coming back,
repeating the word to the point where
it doesn't make any sense anymore.
That thing just seems so strange standing.
So I'm going to imagine like most
people at some point in their career,
whatever there's they're doing,
they all said it's kind of go,
what the fuck am I doing this to
something? We'll just thing I'm doing.
Yeah. If you like rip, paying
too close attention to ballet,
if you're locking into a ballet,
you can enjoy it.
If you're in the moment and you're
just appreciating the movements.
But if you look at it too closely,
then you start to s to step back and
pull back and look it into perspective of
this planet spinning a thousand miles an
hour and a circle around this gigantic
nuclear explosion.
You're like,
look at this asshole and tights
throwing his body through the air.
This is so preposterous.
Like why does anybody give a fuck whether
or not you can sing the words to your,
your play right now? I went
to, my wife was taking Spanish,
uh, or a, a Italian rather. And uh,
one of the things that she did in her
class was they took everyone to an opera.
So we went to an opera.
And so we're sitting there with the
rest of the people in her Italian class
watching this opera.
I'm like,
this has gotta be one of the dumbest
fucking ways to entertain people I've ever
seen. Why the life they're saying in
this language that nobody understands.
It's everything is like everyone falls
in love immediately. So I can't buy it.
There's no reason why these people are
in love with each other so quickly,
like this ready to die.
Like, this is preposterous.
This is made in an era when people didn't
have books. Like they didn't, they,
they bought into this because
they were dumb as shit. But yet
here we are, 21st century. The
entities in a seems absurd as,
and as it would if anybody was coming
here from some different, you know,
galaxy walking in and seeing,
you know,
a standup comic or, or, or, uh, you know,
we're about a band playing on a stage
or a person like getting up so early in
the morning to, uh, you know, to make
bread. I ain't got had, that's food.
I guess that that makes more sense
about to make wine. Yeah. I mean the, I,
you know, you always kind of take
that, take it out of that perspective.
Like somebody comes to this culture and
then there's this thing where you, you,
you stick rocks in your ear and that's
like this thing you do. And there's like,
oh,
there's,
there's better rocks and other rocks
that you're sticking in your year.
And then people start stumbling around
and you know, falling, you know,
bumping into a wall. Like, okay, so you,
you pick up a rock and you put it in
your ear and there's different kinds of
rocks. I feel different and give
you different effects. And there's,
Dear Stephanie, you know, you can,
there's certain rocks that are really
expensive and some that you can just pick
up and know,
stick in your ear,
but you just basically bumped into a wall
afterwards and that's cool. Right? Yeah.
Okay. There you have it. Good luck. Oh,
whoa. Yeah. It just seems so
absurd when you, when you,
when you kind of tick take the, take the
words and replace them with, you know,
other, other objects or
things, you know, wine, food,
I mean food is food, but like
singing a song. I've heard of it.
Yeah. And there's some things that to
the people that participate in them,
our life itself, it's, it's almost, uh,
you know, one of the things that I do, uh,
I've done since I was a, a young
man, this play pool I play,
I played in tournaments and I play like
on a just below professional level and a
to peer.
Should I play pool now?
That's a weird word
that only gets used to.
It only gets used outside of pool shark.
Actually impose a negative term,
meaning someone who distracts you,
why you shooting? They tried to shark
you. Okay? Like if you were shooting,
I was like, Hey, come on man,
you ain't going to make this shot if
I was fucking with you while you were
shooting.
That's called sharking someone.
It's actually poor form and it never
happens in tournaments with the highest
level guys. They never do that.
But to my point was that the two,
the people in that world pools everything.
I mean to watch the great matches from
going from tournament to tournament,
you know? Now nowadays they're there
watching them streaming on the internet,
whether it's through paper view venues or
whether it's through a, you know, some,
some people set up cameras at various
tournaments, but to a person has nothing.
No connection to that world.
It's idiotic.
You're watching these fools are,
there's a Tate, the table never changes.
The six remain in the
exact same spots and it's just about
which way the balls roll around.
Like who gives a fuck? Nothing
changes outside the table. I mean,
this is the microcosm of microcosms,
man. I mean, it's a fucking table.
It doesn't even mean it's level.
It doesn't even move.
It's just a matter of balls colliding
and that that interests you.
But to the people that are involved in
it's every or a person who, you know,
goes to the kind of process
of self discovery. You, you,
you did something and it went in the hole,
you wanted it to go in and you've had
that positive reinforcement and that
encouragement from that,
from that behavior. Uh,
then you follow it more because
like you got some, some hugs,
some kind of accolades, either from
yourself or from someone around you.
So you start pursuing that thing and it
has more about your ego developing in
terms of like the praise that you
got for doing that thing. Yeah.
So you end up, you can see how things
get to that level, you know, watching,
you know, watching, uh, you're,
you know, English, footy.
I was never a footie fan.
Angela had somebody kind of walking
me through what was happening.
And then I recognize something and I was
patted on the back for recognizing this
thing that I still don't have any
fucking idea what I was talking about.
But you know, I'm watching it more
cause I want to see where this goes.
And you were like
six total goals tops and that's like,
that's what we're watching here.
If you're lucky. Yeah. But you know, at
the same time I, you know, not other,
now that I've got sucked
into the rabbit hole,
I completely enjoy what that is.
And there's entire like, you know,
there's probably a bunch of English shoes
right now outside of the studio ready
to kick my ass for even
mentioning it at that.
That might not be something
that's interesting. You know,
like there's like a fury that police,
you didn't call it soccer.
I did not do that. Yeah, I would not.
I would not go that they'll fucking
scream at you if it was football before
football. They have a point. They
do have a point. But yeah, it's,
it's that same thing.
It's like that seeking higher truth in,
in whatever discipline it is.
Whether it's the discipline of football
or wine making or music making or jokes
or Jujitsu, those, those microcosms,
those worlds that exist sort of a holy
on their own and are very difficult to
appreciate by people standing
outside of them. It's a, it's a,
it's a very fascinating aspect of,
of human beings.
So I guess going back to what you
were asking about the, you know,
the Pulitzer for DVD, how I can, you know,
the flexibility of everything that we do.
I guess that's,
that's kind of what that is.
Me and the guys that I work with,
realizing how absurd some of the things
are that we do anyway with our other
projects are with this project.
But we do it anyway cause we're just
really enjoying. We're in the rabbit hole.
We enjoy seeing how far we can take,
uh,
a particular absurd
obsession with something.
And that's absolutely what I
loved and appreciated about it.
Besides the fact that it was funny and
beside the fact that the music was good,
I loved and appreciated the fact that I
could tell it this structure was wholly
your own. This was a, your own, this
is, you just decided to do it this way.
And you know, I don't know if he saw
some of the, some of the shows. The,
we normally have a table and chairs that
we set up at the front of the stage.
Depending on the show, there'll be
different kinds of tables and chairs.
But we always have like some wine and
some stuff on stage because we have
friends that will either,
that have either opened for us or coming
down to see us or I actually playing in
this particular band that while
they're not doing anything,
they sit down and have a glass
of wine onstage and you know,
at the front of the stage, uh,
with us and we've, you know,
we've done a lot of shows like that
where we've had, um, like, you know,
two drummers, two base players and
a couple of extra guitar players.
And then like that rhythm section just
sits down for five songs and just having
wine and cheese at the front of the stage,
just kicking it and then they get back
up and do it because it just felt,
it just feels more casual.
Even Korean around,
I'll sing a couple songs and I'll
sit down and just kind of, you know,
watched the show from the stage that,
is that,
is that something you saw someone else
do or just so I don't know that I've way,
I don't know that I've seen anybody do it.
I'm sure that tasks have been done right.
But I just feel like there's a,
and I've actually tried to,
I've been trying to put this other
show together with no luck. Uh,
well we have several bands kind of
come up and do a very similar thing,
but they play,
you know,
four songs and then they sit down and
maybe there's some kind of segue work,
one of those guys who's playing with that
other band. And then like a band does,
you know,
four songs or five songs and they sit down
and the other guys come back and said,
you just keep rotating, you know, rather
than doing your whole set and like,
here's who I am and this is what I
do kind of, you know, just kind of,
you know, do it almost like a very
well rehearsed rehearsal, you know,
very well rehearsed rehearsal,
like not the final performance,
but like a week before it had a little
glimpse into what it was, you know,
a little bit of the chaos of those guys
getting up there to do their next three
songs. And it's not like them in their
rhythm and in their element of like,
you know, start to finish.
This is our set, right?
It's more like we're going to get up and
do these three songs and then we kind
of have to, and it's not like, you know,
some guys have to get up, you know,
full on Boehner to go do their set and,
you know,
they do the whole thing and you know,
we fucking nailed it.
And then whatever that is.
Uh,
but just the idea of like getting up and
performing those songs and a couple of
ways and put, putting them and
putting us in an uncomfortable,
unfamiliar environment that kind
of helps us just look at it again.
And Ray and joy will be remembered
doing when we started doing it in a way.
So fuck yeah, dude. And working
on that. Yeah, I love it.
That's exactly it man. You know,
if you could find that that's a,
that's how honest energy,
you know,
that's a and an honest form of
expression to, because you know,
you're showing the whole thing,
you're showing the underbelly,
you're pulling the curtain back. Yeah.
And then you're still, but if done right,
it's not necessarily the underbelly,
it's a,
it's a show in and of itself that has,
has depth and movement
and passion and you know,
uncertainty and fear and all the real
stuff that comes along with a movie. Yeah.
And that is within the
songs you're hearing,
there's all that stuff is built
into each one of those stories.
Usually there's some form of
conflict within that song.
That's why they wrote it.
Yeah.
And then seeing that preparation,
it makes you appreciate the final
product even more. So. Yeah,
that's bad ass man. When are you
a, what are you touring right now?
Like what's a just got done with harvest?
I'm doing a lot of writing.
MMM.
Training. Jujitsu. Well I
was to like hurt my hands.
So you sprained it a ahead. My, my
coach and Saint Louis fell on it.
That wasn't me. I was, I was going
the wrong way. It's totally my fault.
I was going the wrong way,
pushing the wrong way and I have my hand
out the wrong way and he went the other
way and like this whole body
like landed on my hand and went,
I can hear like popcorn. Did you
get an MRI or anything? I just,
this happened four hours ago. Doesn't look
that bad. Yeah, I think you'd be okay.
Yeah, I see some swelling. Yeah. So I had
it, I had the, the poor guy on the plane.
I'm like using a puke bags.
I go, can I get some ice?
Like I say my arm on the plane coming
here. Do you think the bones cracked?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
I had to come and do this fucking podcast
instead of going to that hair. You man,
I know what it's like. I gotta get up
and four hours go to the airport. Well,
I mean, the good news is
I'm getting a, um, uh,
Kim say is doing a tattoo
of some tattoo work on me.
So I'm actually kind of out
of the training game for a
minimum of a like a week
or so. Anyway, cause I got to let the,
I got to let the thing he
done getting more am I snakes?
My Arizona Rattler Oh wow.
Is this the guy who's doing
this in California? No. Kim.
Kim Say Kim say shut. You
don't know Kim Kim's work? No.
How dare you? How dare
you? A lot. She, she, yeah.
Where, where is she? Uh, and I'm
going to forget the name of her.
How do you spell her last name?
S.
A. I. G. H. S. A. I. G. H. K. I. M
and Shawn Barber.
Oh Wow. She's wild work,
man. Fantastic stuff. Yeah.
So what town is she in again? She's in
La. Memoria Tattoo Memoir. That's the one,
that's the word I was looking for.
I was going to say heirloom,
but that's my friends that make
food. Oh Wow. No more tattoo.
And where's that at?
It's in kind of the Hollywood,
uh, area, I think. I'm Beverly.
Wow. She's got some
fucking amazing work. Yeah.
She's got some skills to pay the bills.
And Sean's work is awesome too.
That's another
art form that over the last, say, two,
three decades has really come into its
own in a very strange way that didn't
really exist
before. Right. And again, when you look,
when you step back from it, you go,
what are you doing? You're drawing
on yourself. The fuck's your problem.
Go fucking get, just get a pad
of paper and just, you know,
draw a little bit on it.
And then when you don't like it and
you'd draw another one. But no, like,
but you know, but then I,
I get caught up in the, uh,
just the art of tattooing.
And like you said, it's just,
it's come so far and just the people that
are so passionate about it and do such
good work now it's no longer,
you know, Tasmanian devils
and shit. That's for real.
Yeah. I've had both of my
sleeves done by the same guy,
Aaron Dellavedova firm grew tattoo in
San Diego and a grew tattoo is one of
those uh, cool shops where
it's, they're all artists.
You know,
they're all creating these weird pieces
of art when they're not painting.
They're doing,
they're not doing tattoos,
they're painting and
not painting the Dune.
Some guys sculpt some guys in there
fucking around constantly and he just,
this is just one more medium that they
express themselves then. Right. But the,
the medium of tattooing, I mean
there was the tattoos have, you know,
the 1950s in the 1960s and they have no
relation to what is being done today.
Well and the u s yeah, you always had
the core of the Japanese tattooing.
This is like insane,
beautiful stuff.
Insane,
beautiful and,
and ridiculously fucking painful
cause they're doing that tapping
way. That's part of this one. I got
done with that. Oh, did you? In Osaka?
No kidding. So they did it.
How long does that take? Uh,
didn't take much longer than the
gun. I mean, the guy was pretty,
I mean the guy was fantastic.
That was at the chopstick tattoo in Osaka.
That was just so they
use like as fans stick,
they hold it there and the other stick.
Yeah. Tap's over the top of it. Wow.
That's pretty cool house.
How precise can they get with that thing?
It's pretty precise. I said,
get in there, buddy. Yeah,
that's pretty bad. I love the Thai
style. Once they're doing too, like the,
I'm going to have them do a drag and
I'm actually going to talk to, to,
to the memoir is the number three,
five, three. What is that? That's a,
it's part of my wine story.
I don't know.
Can you tell us a store? No, it's
a secret really. You have secrets?
It's a little fucking
tap in your email sun.
At least that secret
within the secret's out.
And so you had that guy and do that.
Would that tapping style with the bamboo?
I think Tara Patrick had her whole
arm done that way. She's like,
it was huge. Japanese sleeve. I'm pretty
sure she had it done the traditional way,
like the uh, the, the full, I don't
know what the word is. They uh,
they do it. It's funny when you go to
Japan, you can't show your tattoos.
I was a at an OBL both in the
gym. Yeah. They made me cover up.
They told me I have to wear a,
go back to my room and put a
long sleeve shirt on and a,
I couldn't train as you're
a fucking derelict. Yeah.
I tell I try to let them know
I'm not, yeah, that's her, uh,
her tattoo there.
I'm pretty sure that's done
the traditional way or at
least part of it is. Yeah.
In the Japanese culture, that's not
a good thing. That's a no, it's bad.
That's the Yakuza and it's really
interesting because they're the ones who
created such beautiful,
these,
these beautiful full piece
body designs like that,
those bodysuits that are actually
just one long flowing piece of art.
That's the origin of that,
but not respected in the
country where it came from.
It's funny. Yeah. It's kind of
fun. I got jumped. Please society,
please.
What'd they do?
Maybe put the robe on. I had to I
to put like sweat pants on and a,
and a top to be in the gym.
Where were you? In Japan. Which part? That
was in, I think that was in Tokyo. Yeah.
That's where I was too. There were, there
were not having it [inaudible] it's a,
if you have anything on your neck,
you have to wear a turtleneck.
I think if you have a tattoo
scene and act like it's,
it's much more discriminatory
than it is in America.
Politely discriminatory. Yeah. They're
very polite, polite about it. Well,
there are so polite in such a strange way.
It's a,
it was a really interesting culture
and we went there pretty shortly after
Fukushima where there was this
weird feeling of distrust for,
uh, the, the government's assessment
of the damage and the dangers. And, uh,
we were,
we had this long conversation with this
taxi driver because he had to drive us
from the venue all the way down to Tokyo.
And it's about an hour's drive.
And so he was a,
he spoke pretty good English and he
was saying that for the first time,
people are, uh, openly
starting to question,
we're not the government's being
honest with them about yeah. Without,
they can eat vegetables,
whether or not, you know,
the ground is radioactive and
they're Fisher edible. Right.
And I, and I would have to
agree with that. That's, that's,
that's starting to happen. Yeah.
That's a scary fucking thing.
And that they might have
ruined their country.
They might have to bail because
it could get worse. I mean,
there was another
earthquake just last week.
There was a 7.3 off the coast of
Japan. Yeah. Yeah. It was another one.
It didn't cause a tsunami,
but it could have, I mean,
all it takes is the plates go
this way instead of that way,
and then the water's coming.
Yeah. And if it does,
they're fucked.
Yeah. That's it. You know there's a, there
was a beer that a friend of mine had it.
Uh, it is local so she plays
and I went in and was like, Hey,
can I get the ads? Some of that? He
goes, no. I said, I said, what happened?
They sit all of the earthquake.
So that's there.
That stopped production and particularly
because no, it's gone. The family's gone.
The beer has gone, the
building's gone. They're gone.
Gone, gone. Like never
coming back. Yeah. Yeah.
You see some of the damage
that that by the way,
that ain't shit compared to some of the
fucking tsunamis that they know have hit
different parts of the world.
That's why I always laugh whenever I
drive by Malibu. How's the Malibu today?
And I was driving by and I
was looking at these houses,
they have perched over the ocean
and I was like, sleds, boy,
there's no guarantee that's
going to be there to wild.
Those are just sleds with,
they're basically playing a long extended
game of musical chairs and they know
for sure one day and the music's going
to stop and their houses are going to
have for sure go flying out into the
ocean. But when the Michigan man,
all the snow, you'd always have, you
know, he could do bobsledding stuff.
Can I just slid down the hill? And
that was, when I see those houses,
that's all I can think of is sledding in
the winter. Yeah, she can. Well they'll,
they'll get a raised one day.
I guess if you're like way
up a one of those bluffs,
you probably got a pretty good shot of,
not of,
not falling completely in the ocean,
but those things have massive landslides
too. There was a couple of years ago,
there was a news report where these
people were waking up in the middle of the
night,
these horrible cracking noises and they
realize that their houses were sliding
off the side of this hill down into
this valley and it just gives out,
you know,
you decided to put a foundation and
the ground that decided to not be there
anymore. Right. And it all
just didn't. Giant, huge, 30,
40 acre chunks just slides down and
takes these $5 million houses with it.
And that's the fear. It then at worth $5
million anymore. Not Anymore. If I may,
I think you're correct. And I think even
if she wanted to reclaim that land, boy,
it's tough to pinpoint where
your house used to be. Yeah.
Good luck with that survey. Yeah. Yeah.
Those dudes with the sticks
looking through that hole. Yeah.
They're going to have to do a lot of
measuring. That was me in the military.
Did you do that? That's what I did.
What'd you do in the military? Uh,
we put in grid coordinates for,
uh,
like the tank batteries
to pull in and you know,
if you're gonna if you're going to shove
a big missile in a tube and launch it
somewhere,
he had Kevin,
he had to know where you are and
to know where it's going basically.
So that's what we would do with people.
Put the survey points.
What branch of the military army, how
long were you in for? Three. Three years.
Well, six years total. What year was this?
82 to 85 reserves from 85 to Aka.
That's you buy boom,
you handsome fast out of wig.
It's just real, you know.
Did you get anything out of being
in the military? Yeah. Discipline.
Yeah. Just, you know, just again,
just being, being responsible. Uh,
response ability.
The ability to respond.
Yeah. People that have gone
through that. Um, it's a, it's,
it's very interesting to see.
I
had a friend who was a real lazy and Kinda
shiftless and never got anything done
and then went away,
went to bootcamp,
came back and this motherfucker
always folded his napkin after that,
sat up straight and got shit
done. And I was like, wow,
they turn this dude around.
Like they're really did. I mean,
I wouldn't recommend it today because
joining today you have a high likelihood
of either being forced to assassinate
someone for the government or finding
yourself in a position where
you really wouldn't want to be.
And people are shooting at, you
know, that don't like Americans.
And unless it's your calling, I wouldn't
really recommend it, but God damn,
for some people it really is a,
a game changer.
I agree. Um, yeah. And you know, not all,
not everyone can make it through it. It's
a lot of guys, it kind of washed out,
you know, during that
whole, uh, basic training.
What made you join College Fund
for Art School? Really? Yeah.
Well,
you're pretty convinced that we weren't
going to go to war during those times
lately. I was like war,
you know, I didn't,
I just didn't believe it.
And then, uh, I got, uh,
I got appointed to go, I got this
through long process, but uh, uh,
basically it got handed a,
an opportunity to go to west point by
going to the preparatory school for a year
and uh,
got to the end.
Like when I finally got my
appointment to go to west point,
they said basically you have to forfeit
your army college fund to go to art
school. And I didn't really go
into be a career military person.
I kind of went into get college fund so
I can go pursue the arts. But you know,
but you're being, again, I was being, my
behavior is being reinforced as far as my,
the way I was excelling as
in, in um, in the military.
Um, so it was very tempting to go, I
could be an officer, let's do that.
And then you get, you know, I got to
that moment where I had to like add them,
make that decision.
In that moment you have basically I had
like three hours to check the yes box
then.
Except my appointment or check the no
box and go back into the regular army and
they go back to and go to art school and
I chose, I chose art school. All right.
And I, if I had not done
that, I would have provided,
I made it through west point,
which is not a guarantee.
If I'd have made it through west point,
I would have been in the first
Gulf war as a lieutenant.
Wow. That's fucking crazy. Golf for one,
I think they call it.
I had a friend who,
he's a cop and he was in the army reserve,
the army reserve for 20 years and had
less than a month to go till he was out
for 20 years and they shipped him
to Iraq for a year and a half.
Come again.
He was in the reserves and the reserves
during the Iraq war or after September
11 they just started sending people
over there. You were under contract.
That's it. It does. It didn't
matter if you had a month ago.
During that month you were assigned a
year and a half tour of Iraq and he went
not just once. He went and came
back and they sent him again.
They sent him twice and he did three years
in Iraq when he had less than a month
ago. And there was nothing
he could do about it.
His whole life was thrown into
chaos. You, it was his relationship.
His job is everything
gone. Yep. Sorry, you,
you live in Iraq now. You, you're
over there. You're a soldier. I mean,
he is a fascinating thing to watch.
Like,
well at least he made you a
free life. He got lucky. Yeah.
He came back different though. I'll
tell you that. He came back, uh,
you could tell he had seen some shit.
There's no avoiding that. I mean, he,
uh, he saw combat duty
and wasn't planning on it.
So thought he was getting out, thought
he was going home, thought reserve,
met reserve, you know, thought,
thought 30 days meant 30 days. Nope.
No,
it means to one and a half year tours,
or at least all in total was somewhere
around three years. The beach.
Well, we don't have water, but we got Sam.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I guess there's good to be gotten
from almost everything, but uh,
but for you at least it was a
positive. It's dyed dodge, you know,
quite metaphorically and literally
dodged a bullet. Yeah. Wow.
That must be something you think about
often. But you know, I could see,
you know, I could see how
I could've excelled at that
and done well for, you know,
done my part in that setting.
Uh,
I have an aptitude for it and I have a
lot of my friends are law enforcement and
a military, so, uh, I get
along with him. Well, you know,
I also have all my crazy liberal
friends that I get along with. Well,
so I think I just would have been,
if it would've,
it was a path that I would've chosen,
I would've just done
whatever I could do with it.
The law enforcement friends,
I bet understand your friendship with
the crazy hippies and liberals more than
the crazy liberals. Understand your
real relationships with law enforcement.
Absolutely. And that funny. Yeah.
Yeah. God bless him. God bless
him. All the open minded liberals.
Yeah.
Yes.
There's not that many of those are there.
Well it boils down to it.
There's a lot of aggressive progressive's.
Yeah. And I, I noticed
that. Yeah. And you know,
coming from that background of being,
you know,
supposedly like the Liberal Democrat,
it's pretty amazing.
Well, they have this idea and they think
that it's right and they think that they
should, uh, violently, uh, tried to, uh,
support that idea. You know, whether or
not other people have that idea or not,
they think that their ideas
correct and their ideas on
the right side of history.
And so it's something to be
something to be violently pursued.
Baboon. Yeah. But boom, I don't
know. I don't know who's right.
I don't think any of them are, the truth
is in the middle somewhere. Right? Yeah.
Listen, man, I've got to go to the
airport and I think five hours. All right,
so let's wrap this bitch up. I
just, I just came from the airport.
Thank you for doing this, man. I'm
glad you did. I'm glad you did.
You mean you literally pulled right
up the cars out front and then, um,
if people want to watch DVD,
how can people watch this, uh,
is coming out on the, uh, I think
the 26th of November or the,
what is a poster for a DVD?
A show live in Phoenix,
um, comes out, uh,
on the 26th as well as the perfect circle,
um,
box set and the songs from this,
uh,
where could they get
those on, on that? Yeah,
they're on this deal will be released, uh,
uh, as, uh, on iTunes or probably I think,
yeah, we're doing this separate. You can
get, she get the live album off of iTunes.
Just the songs. Beautiful. Yeah.
Beautiful. Well go get it folks. And uh,
follow on Twitter posts suffer on
Twitter and uh, there it is right there.
Dv D and soundtrack available.
What did it say? November what? 26,
26 as well as the,
that as well as the perfect circle
one as well. Live at red rocks.
Good Sunday. We got the documentary
guys. Like you can't look,
can't talk to the camera. Oh yeah. I'm
not supposed to talk all, no, I know. No,
keep forgetting
character when you do this.
No, no. That was like the, I mean,
literally that was a, with Laura and uh,
me and that costume, we were like, that
came out for the weekend. I'm like,
what are we going to do? And,
and Mike, her husband was like,
just had a new Camry. You
wanted to try out, you know,
I think it was the canon
five d or whatever. It's just
trying to like, you know,
let's just get some footage,
see what we get.
And we just did all that and we went,
did we just do that? Like no script.
Just kind of went, well let's do this.
Let's do this. And then, you know,
went to Wa like actually spent like two
hours in Walmart grabbing stuff just for
that day to see what we could come up
with the come up with the costumes that
the Halloween shirt and everything was
just like on a quick trip to Walmart to
see what we can come up with.
That was beautiful.
You're a beautiful man, man.
God bless you. And men like you.
Thank you. Onward, right folks?
That's it. This ends, uh,
we will put all the commercials on it.
Stick this bitch up on iTunes and we'll
see you on Friday with Dan Carlin from
hardcore history.
Big Kiss,
Ma.
Okay.